Die zwei Sprechstunden. Das heißt, das Chaosradio, es besteht eine große Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es sich bei dieser Ausgabe um die Folgenummer 183 bis 187 handelt.
Einigen wir uns mal auf 186.
Meinst du, ich fand 185, hätte ich aber irgendwie so ein bisschen runder gefunden, aber gut, was kann man machen. Also hier ist Chaosradio 186.
Ja, ist eine runde Zahl. Ja, per Definition.
Ach so, findest du per Definition. Na gut, also hier ist Chaosradio 186. Einen wunderschönen guten Abend. Im Studio sind Henrik und Simon. Hallo Henrik, hallo Simon. Guten Abend. Simon macht in Gebäudesicherheit. Henrik macht in Computersicherheit. Und das hier ist praktisch die zweite Ausgabe, ne die Fortsetzung der Sendung von vor genau einem, ne genau zwei Jahren, ist es jetzt 2003?
Ziemlich genau, ja.
Ziemlich genau.
Wir wissen noch was drauf, aber...
Echt, war das nicht Januar?
Ja, aber so 20. Januar, 22. Januar oder so.
Ja gut, aber im letzten Tag, wo Chaosradio im Januar ist, war. Damals ging es um, ja was, Aufsperrtechnik?
Ja, wir wollten eigentlich über mechanische Sicherheitstechnik reden, über elektromechanische Sicherheitstechnik und über elektronische Zutrittskontrollsysteme. Und hatten so viele spannende Dinge zu erzählen und so rege Anrufer, dass wir da nicht ganz fertig geworden sind.
Stattdessen seid ihr gekommen bis?
Na, wir hatten so die mechanischen Zylinder durch, verschiedene Aufsperrtechniken, Lockpicking und stehen jetzt quasi vor der Elektronik.
Vor der Elektronik? Ich hätte aber trotzdem noch ein paar Fragen zur Mechanik, aber dafür hassen mich dann alle, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie, kannst du ja die Sendung annehmen, ne kann ich eben nicht, weil nämlich der Server nicht geht. Wer ist denn eigentlich dafür verantwortlich, dass der Server nicht geht? Ja, also da wollen wir jetzt keine Schuldzuweisungen zum besten geben. Ihr hattet die mechanische Schließtechnik tatsächlich komplett abgearbeitet. Was ist das sicherste Schloss, das ich mir in die Tür einbauen kann?
Das ist schwierig zu beantworten. Warum? Es gibt sehr unterschiedliche Ansätze, also ganz unterschiedliche Techniken. Und es gibt Leute, die spezialisieren sich auf das eine Schloss oder auf das Überwinden des einen Schlosses und andere wieder auf das Überwinden von anderen Schlössern. Also es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze und es ist eine Frage, die man nicht so pauschal beantworten kann.
Das klingt jetzt so, als wäre es vollkommen egal, was für ein Schloss ich mir einbauen würde. Funktionieren eh alle nicht. Oder sind eh alle nicht sicher noch?
Nein, das kann man so nicht sagen. Also es gibt durchaus auch mechanische Schließsysteme, die sehr schwierig zu überwinden sind oder kaum zu überwinden sind oder für die meisten gar nicht zu überwinden sind, ohne die Tür zu beschädigen.
Wobei bei der Nachbarin von einem Freund haben sie neulich eingebrochen. Die Tür sieht aus, als hätten sie das Ding, weiß ich nicht, was mit dem Vorschlaghammer bearbeitet oder sowas, also da sind sie dann halt durch.
Keiner im Haus hat es gehört.
Das ist eigentlich das Interessante, obwohl das Haus voller Rentnerinnen ist, die eigentlich den ganzen Tag zu Hause sitzen sollten.
Aber es interessiert die Leute einfach nicht mehr.
Das heißt, sie hören es und hören trotzdem weg? Also sie hören es und denken sich, ach man, machen die wieder Randale da oben? Ja, auch das, ja. Also du machst das ja hauptberuflich, Türen öffnen. Oder eben Türen sichern, sodass man sie nicht so leicht öffnen kann. Was erzählen die Leute denn so von den Nachbarn? Keiner hat's gehört?
Also die meisten sagen immer, sie haben nichts gehört. Und dann ist die Sache alle nicht.
Witten wir uns den elektronischen Sachen? Du hast Husten, du Ärmster.
Ja, so ein bisschen.
Das einzige elektronische Schließsystem, das stimmt gar nicht. Ich kenne zwei elektronische Schließsysteme. Das eine ist mit Fingerabdruck. Ich glaube, das ist nicht sonderlich sicher.
Ja, alle Biometrie ist nicht sicher.
Alle Biometrie ist nicht sicher.
Oder kommt auf den Angriffsvektor an. Aber wenn es darum geht, das Zutrittsmedium zu kopieren, dann ist man bei mir Biometrie natürlich schon wieder in der sehr unsicheren Seite gelegt.
Ja, aber es gibt doch so Iris Scanner oder zumindest im Agentenfilm.
Ja, also bei Iris und Retina muss man immer ein bisschen aufpassen. Iris Scanner machst du halt ein Foto der Person. Beim Retina Scanner wird es schon etwas besser, aber da muss dann halt auch das Lesegerät quasi ganz nah an den Augapfel ran, was dann auf wenig Gegenliebe bei den Benutzern stößt. Deswegen nutzt das auch keiner.
Also ganz nah an den Augapfel ran, wie beim Augenarzt? Also so Kontaktlinsendichte?
Ja, häufig ja.
Oh, das ist ja eklig. Was ist denn dann mit den Dingern, ich kenne die wirklich nur aus dem Agentenfilm, wo dann so ein Scan-Balton über das Auge fährt, wie so ein Laser.
Ja, das ist bloß damit der Zuschauer vom Agentenfilm, dann sieht das was passiert.
Das ist für so Idioten wie mich.
Ja, das ist ähnlich wie diese Scandisplays, die auch sehr häufig bei Fingerabdruckszenen oder Hand-Sensoren vorkommen. Dann ist da auch gleich ein, das ist nicht nur ein Sensor, sondern auch ein Display, das passiert eher selten in der Realität.
Es gibt auch in Anführungsstrichen Alarmanlagen, die genau diese Funktion haben. Das ist einfach nur ein Kasten, der an der Wand hängt und der macht so einen senkrechten Laserstrich, der durch den Raum geht, so von links nach rechts und links nach rechts. Also vor dem Schaufenster sieht es beeindruckend aus. Hat keinerlei Relevanz.
Ach, das ist dann wirklich so ein Mission Impossible Ding, was da so rumpinkt.
Aber das ist ja geil.
So was will ich.
Sind die teuer? Der wichtige Teil ist dann der Aufkleber an der Schaufensterscheibe. Das hat man früher im Auto ja auch gehabt, dass man eine blinkende LED eingebaut hat.
Stimmt, ich erinnere mich. Was bedeutet das heutzutage, wenn eine blinkende LED im Auto eingebaut ist? Bedeutet das, dass da irgendwas arbeitet, oder bedeutet das, dass eine blinkende LED ins Auto eingebaut ist?
Na mindestens, dass die Batterie noch nicht leer ist.
Na gut, ich hab übrigens was vergessen. Ich hab vergessen Platten mitzunehmen. Oh, so ein Mist. Lad ich mir noch mal schnell ein paar CC-Mix-Tapes runter. Und hab die falschen Mix-Tapes runtergeladen. Das heißt, wenn wir heute Musik... Ich weiß, ich hab früher, ist ja lange her, dass ich Chaosradio gemacht habe. Ist ja mittlerweile 5, 5, fast 6 Jahre her.
Willkommen zurück.
Ja, hallo. Ich bin aber nur die Vertretung. Also Markus ist ja in dieser ominösen Pause, die man hier beim RBB immer machen muss. So alle 6 Jahre. Das heißt, ich putze hier nur. Ihr werdet mich dann auch wieder los. Irgendwann, wenn das Studio einigermaßen sauber ist. Früher hab ich das immer so gemacht, dass ich immer so ein Musikbett drunter liegen hatte.
So. Feuer.
Was ja irgendwie ganz fesch ist. Und immer, wenn ich dachte, jetzt haben wir genug gelabert, hab ich die Musik so hochgezogen und was stehen lassen, damit wir auch ein bisschen verschnaufen können, eine Mate trinken. Also ist das okay oder ist das irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, kein Sinn, dass das auch nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hör so selten Radio. Also was zeitgemäßes kann nicht.
Ich komm von dir, ich auch nicht, keine Ahnung.
Ja, dann nennt man das einfach Retro und dann passt das wieder.
Chaosradio 186, glauben wir, ist hier. Elektronisches Schließsystem ist unser Thema. Das ist hier eine Hörertalk-Sendung, weil Stäbler-Monophritze in dessen Rahmen das Chaosradio stattfindet. Das heißt, ihr seid natürlich herzlich eingeladen anzurufen und euch zu beteiligen, qualifiziert zum Thema beizutragen. Ich mach's wie früher, wir sind hier nicht die Windows-Hotline.
Genau, Windows kommt tatsächlich erstaunlich häufig vor, aber ja.
Windows kommt häufig vor?
Bei Schließsystemen, bei Elektronischen, ja ja. Ist halt wie bei normaler Software auch.
Ja gut, das Studio ist übrigens auch, läuft auch auf Windows.
Ja, ich seh das schon.
Woran? Was funktioniert nicht?
Noch funktioniert alles.
Kommen wir zur Schließtechnik.
Ja, was wollen wir eigentlich erreichen mit Schließtechnik? Wir haben da so eine Tür in den meisten Fällen, damit kennen sich viele Leute aus. Die ist hoffentlich zu, wenn man sie nicht benutzt. Und wir wollen, dass sie aufgeht, wenn jemand davor steht, der eine Berechtigung dafür hat. Und hauptsächlich hoffentlich nur genau dann. Und das kann man halt wie früher mit irgendwelcher Mechanik machen. Kann man machen, man kann neuerdings, hat man Elektronik, kann man ein bisschen Elektronik einbauen. Wenn wir dann schon mal Elektronik eingebaut haben, dann haben wir nämlich noch ganz viele Dinge, die wir dazukriegen können. Dann ist es zum Beispiel einfacher, verlorene Schlüssel oder Schlüssel von Mitarbeitern, die abgehauen sind oder sonst da was zu sperren, was ja sonst bei einem Schloss eher schwierig ist, einen existierenden Schlüssel zu sperren. Oder man könnte auch das Schloss nur zu bestimmten Zeiten aufgehen lassen, die Putzfrauensteuerung.
Halt mal den Gedanken fest, du sagtest, es ist schwierig, einen Schlüssel zu sperren. Das heißt, es ist nicht unmöglich, einen Schlüssel zu sperren. Wie geht das? Wie sperrt man einen mechanischen Schlüssel, Simon?
Na, einen mechanischen Schlüssel kann man in den meisten Schließsystemen nur sperren, indem man die betroffenen Zylinder austauscht.
Ja, das würde ich in der Schließ- rich fassen.
Das ist ja im weitesten Sinne nicht schwer.
Und an alle berechtigten Personen neue Schlüssel verteilen.
Es gibt ein Schließsystem, da fällt mir aber gerade der Name nicht ein. Da gibt es eine zweite Plättchenreihe in diesem Schließsystem und ein Kügelchen. Und da gibt es einen Schlüssel, mit dem kann man dann einmal rumschließen. Und dann funktioniert die zweite Schließ- ebene. Aber ich komme gerade auf den Namen nicht. Aber vielleicht fällt es mir unterwegs noch ein.
Das heißt, ich kann einen Schlüssel verlieren und kann das Ding dann komplett auf Null zurücksetzen.
Und Elektronik heißt halt auch, dass man häufig noch irgendeine Art Log-Datei da drin hat, die dann einem sagt, wer wann, zu welcher Zeit, wahrscheinlich nicht warum, aufgeschlossen hat. Aber das einfach nur, wenn man Elektronik drin hat. Man muss nicht nur Elektronik haben. Das ist also jetzt mehr so Simons Thema. Ich komme dann später, wenn wir nur Elektronik haben. Man kann halt Elektronik mit der Mechanik kombinieren.
Und da gibt es unterschiedliche Ansätze. Also ganz viele reden davon, dass sie Elektronik und Mechanik kombinieren. Mir fallen jetzt aus dem Stilgreifen nur zwei Systeme ein, die das auch wirklich machen. Oder drei Systeme. Aber sind vielleicht auch noch eins, viel mehr. Wo wirklich tatsächlich in einem Zylinder sowohl mechanische Komponenten abbefragt werden, als auch elektronische Komponenten. Und das auf unterschiedlichen Wegen. Also es gibt da kontaktbasierte Systeme, also wo so ein richtiger Drahtkontakt am Schlüssel dran ist, der dann geschlossen wird, dann gibt es auch Sachen, wo über eine Art Antenne das induktiv übertragen wird.
Ich hab gerade so Wegversperre im Auto, ist das nicht sowas? Das ist so die rudimentär Anwendung.
Das ist so ähnlich, wobei die Auto-Weckversperre so ein bisschen in die Richtung geht, zwei Systeme sehr nah beieinander. Also im Prinzip hat man da ein Schließsystem und in der Verkleidung noch eine Antenne außen rum, die so eine Art RFID-Transponder auslöst.
Genau, also soweit ich es verstanden habe, macht die Wegversperre im Auto mehr oder weniger den Lenkrad, also der Schlüssel, die Lenkrad-Sperre auf und die Wegversperre schaltet dann den Motor frei, die Elektronik schaltet den Motor frei. Und das habe ich dann teilweise, ich habe mit Autos nicht so viel Erfahrung, ich habe mal eine Bedienungsanleitung gesehen, da las ich das so, als könnte man einfach jeden beliebigen Schlüssel dieser Automarke nehmen und den einfach anlernen. Das sah dann so aus, als ob die mechanisch alle gleich wären und dann bloß noch die Elektronik, je nachdem umgestellt wird.
Das ändert sich dann doch nicht, selbst wenn es auf Elektronik umgestellt wird. Ich weiß, wir sind früher, also sehr, sehr früh, also vor über 20 Jahren auf den Schrottplatz gegangen, haben einfach alte Autoschlüsse gesammelt, weil du hast sowieso, wenn du zehn VW-Schlüssel hattest, hast du praktisch zehn VW aufgekriegt damals. Das war relativ simpel.
Also soll ja nicht nur in der Vergangenheit geklappt haben.
So, nachdem ich mein Auto jetzt auf andere Weise gesichert habe, wegen der Schlüsselsache, wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Auf die Autos wollten wir erst mal nicht eingehen. Das ist nochmal ein zu breites eigenes Thema. Wir waren ja bei der Elektromechanik hängen geblieben und viele Anbieter werben damit, dass sie elektromechanische Schließzylinder haben. Aber eigentlich ist es nur ein klassischer mechanischer Zylinder und im Schlüsselkopf ist ein Transponder und sie haben entweder einen mechanischen Zylinder, den man bedient oder einen elektronischen Zylinder, den man bedient, wo die meisten sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie auf der innen und auf der außen Seite so einen formschönen, meist völlig überdimensioniert großen Doppelknauf haben.
Da muss ja noch was rein in den Knauf.
Da muss ja noch was rein in den Knauf, genau.
Es muss vor allen Dingen Badass aussehen.
Na ja, aber so.
Wenn ich viel Geld für irgendwie so ein elektromechanisches Schließsystem ausgebe, dann will ich halt auch, dass das geil aussieht und nicht irgendwie so was.
Also ich glaube, wenn du viel Geld ausgibst, dann willst du, dass man es gar nicht mehr sieht.
Wenn du sehr viel Geld ausgibst.
Aber das Problem ist ja, mit Sachen, die rausstehen oder so, so ein Anlächeln, dass die auch zum Spielen verleiten.
Deswegen sind die auf die Innenseite hoffentlich. Meistens manchmal.
So und ja, der Hintergrund ist, dass der auch kaputtgehen kann oder abgeschlagen werden kann. Deswegen haben da einige Hersteller immer schon relativ weit gedacht. Also sie haben auf der Außenseite nur eine meist recht unintelligente Laserantenne und haben immerhin die Elektronik auf der Innenseite, so dass das Ganze ein bisschen sicherer wird. Aber es gibt halt auch Türen, ja da gibt es keine Innen- und keine Außenseite, weil es halt Durchgangstüren gibt. Oder Türen in Zauntoren. Und da ist es dann problematisch.
Aber kann man es da nicht in Rahmen verbauen?
Ja, wenn man es in Rahmen verbaut, dann wird es mit der Nachrüstbarkeit, der Austauschbarkeit wieder sehr kompliziert. Da können wir nachher nochmal bei den elektronischen Schließsystemen drauf, weil das charmante an so einem Zylinder ist, da ist ein definiertes Loch an der Tür. Man steckt ihn rein, schraubt ihn fest und fertig. Aber Rahmen, individuell, umständlich gleich teuer.
Aber wie kriegst du denn dann in so einem Zylinder ein elektromagnetisches Schließsystem? Weil so viel Platz ist da ja gar nicht drin, oder? Oder gibt es die dann auch? Die skalieren dann hoch.
Also was ist heutzutage in den Handys alles drin?
Ja, also Platz ist da knapp genug. Nicht notwendigerweise immer genug Platz sicher zu machen, aber also wir hatten da glaube ich, ich war nicht dabei, aber ich habe Berichte gehört, sie haben sich beim CTC mal so ein System angeguckt, wo dann die Elektronik zwar auch innen war, aber die Kabelführung so war, dass im Wesentlichen dieser eine Kontakt, den man betätigen musste, damit die Tür aufgeht, von außen erreichbar war. War mir dann wieder mit irgendwelche Gatschmasse zugeklebt, sodass wenn man weiß, wo man mit der Nadel reinstechen muss, den einfach so betätigen konnte.
Wie funktionieren die Dinger denn dann? Also was passiert in so einem elektromechanischen Schließsystem?
Also, gibt es verschiedene?
Ich kenne da nicht alle, aber so.
Was passiert in einem elektromechanischen Schließsystem, die du kennst?
Also der klassische Fall ist, dass man ein Element hat, was eine Federspannung hat und zwangsbedient durch den Schlüssel ist. In dem Moment, wo man es rauszieht, drückt eine Fehler auf das Element und es ist definitiv wieder verschlossen, so dass man beim Rausziehen des Schlüsseln oder zum Verschließen des Zylinders keine Energie braucht. Und beim Entriegeln wurde es so gemacht, dass man da nicht einen Bolzen wegzieht, sondern im Prinzip nur die Bewegung des Bolzens zulässt. Und das Wegschieben passiert erst durch die Drehung des Schlüssels, sodass man mit möglichst wenig Energie das Ganze bewegen kann.
Das heißt, der elektromagnetische Teil dabei ist eigentlich sowas wie Servolenkung im Auto oder so, also eine Unterstützung?
Nein, eigentlich nicht eine Unterstützung, sondern ein ganz kurzer Impuls, der einen Nebenteil frei gibt, sag ich jetzt mal.
Irgendwie sowas wie ein Hebel, sodass sie es normalerweise frei dreht zum Beispiel und dann nur dadurch, dass man den ganz kurzen kleinen Winkel verschiebt, das plötzlich greift und sich bewegen lässt.
Ist das möglich für das Radio, also ohne es aufzumahlen, zu beschreiben, wie solche Systeme tatsächlich aussehen? Also weil so abstrakt kann ich mir das jetzt ein bisschen vorstellen, aber konkret nicht.
Also ein bisschen besser lässt sich das vielleicht vorstellen oder erklären bei so einem Doppelknaufzylinder. Da ist halt eine Welle, die geht durch den ganzen Zylinder durch. In der Mitte ist halt die Schließnase und außen dieser Knauf, der dreht halt frei. Und auf der Innenseite ist dann im Prinzip ein Elektromagnet, der anzieht und dann wird halt ein Zahnritzel mit dieser Welle verbunden, wo man ja einfach nur diese Zahnritzel einen kleinen Stück beiseite zieht mit dem Elektromagnet und dann dreht sich in die Welle mit. Und dann kann man den Zylinder betätigen.
Wobei das nicht mehr sonderlich sicher ist, ne? Also dann kann ich ja von außen auch mit Magneten kommen.
Es soll schon Schließsysteme gegeben haben, wo genau das funktioniert hat.
Wo man dann mit so einem starken Ringmagneten zum Beispiel um den Knauf rum und dann dreht sich das plötzlich doch. Andere Systeme gingen dann wohl angeblich einfach mit Fliegkraft, wenn man also den Knauf ganz schnell dreht.
Schnell genug dreht, ja auch schön.
Oder auch, ja das ist ja das Problem mit diesen Drehknöpfen oder diesen Knaufzylindern, weil die verleiten halt einfach zum Spielen. Also diese Fliegkraft, man legt halt einen Gürtel rum oder so, und zieht dann einmal kräftig.
Frisierter Grillmotor.
Ja und wenn der halt raus steht, dann kann man bei manchen auch einfach überdimensional stark auf diesen Knauf schlagen und dann staucht die Welle halt innen ein bisschen. Und das reicht dann auch schon, um die Schließnase mitzunehmen.
Ich sollte mir also, ich hab gewusst, dass heute so was passiert, so alle Ideen, die ich so hab, wo ich denke, ah, dann mach ich mir so ein Regel, dann mach ich mir so ein Schloss und dann bricht bei mir keiner mehr ein. Am Ende der Sendung werde ich meine Tür einfach aufstehen lassen und Leute dafür bezahlen, dass sie meine Wohnung bewachen.
Ja, das ist dann wieder versicherungstechnisch doof. Also was so ähnlich ist, was ich neulich schon mal gesehen habe, lag auch im Club rum, ist so ein Safe, wie man halt im Supermarkt kriegt, wo man dann im wesentlichen Namen gleich im Prinzip funktioniert, dass es sich nur drehen lässt, wenn man vorher den Code eingegeben hat, wo man dann auch nur im richtigen Timing von oben draufschlagen und gleichzeitig drehen musste, damit sich halt dieses kleine Ding bewegt und plötzlich aufgeht. Das hab ich tatsächlich selber, obwohl ich keine Ahnung davon hatte, nach dem dritten Mal hingekriegt.
Safe ist ja so ein Stichwort. Jetzt facepalmt die halbe Hörerschaft, aber ist mir egal. Wie funktionieren eigentlich diese Safes, wo nur so ein so ein Drehrad dran ist? Das musst du doch wissen. Du bist doch auf Sperrtechnik. Jetzt guckt Simon komisch.
Also Tresore sind so eine eigene Sache für sich. Da bin ich ganz ehrlich da.
Weil das würde mich echt mal interessieren. Du weißt, was ich meine, wenn so ein Rad dran ist und dann sitzt halt irgendwie David Niven mit so einem Stethoskop da und hört ab und macht klicke die Klicke und dann geht der Safe auf. Wie das funktioniert, würde ich ja echt gerne mal wissen. Frage an die Hörerschaft. 03317797110 ist unsere Nummer. Ich wüsste ganz gerne, wie da so ein Safe eigentlich funktioniert. Also wo nur so ein Drehrad dran ist. Fünf nach rechts, drei nach links, sieben nach rechts und dann geht der Safe auf oder dann kann man es entriegeln.
Ich glaube, das ist im Radio tatsächlich sehr schwierig. Also ich habe es mal gesehen, aber ja, es gibt da irgendwelche Dinge, die aneinandergreifen. So kann man es sehr schön beschreiben. Ich glaube genauer auch nicht.
Vielleicht hat hier jemand den Mut, das trotzdem zu versuchen. Marc hier anrufen. Wie gesagt 03317797110. Das Chaosradio 186, das ihr hört. Wir rufen uns langsam ein in die elektronischen Schließsysteme. Falls so ein paar Nachfragen kommen, die Musik, wie gesagt, ich hatte vergessen, eigene Platten mitzunehmen, darum hab ich schnell was runtergeladen. Das ist CC Musik, also frei, kostenlos, legal, downloadbar und weitergebbar, verteilbar. Viel mehr zähl ich, dass es Chaos Radio gibt. Man merkt, dass ich schon länger nicht mehr da war. Ist von Mixotic, mixotic.net, Klänge der Nacht, Volume 2 von Tom Larsen, Mixotic Nummer 76. Chaosradio 186, elektronische Schließsysteme, ist unser Thema heute Abend und falls ihr euch wundert, warum ich bei der Uhrzeit so stammle, ich sehe die Uhr nicht, weil da gerade eine Lautsprecherbox davor hängt und ich wollte nur, eigentlich will ich nur Mitleid haben. Zu Gast im Studio sind Simon und Henrik. Wo war ich denn geliehen?
Bei Saves, aber ich glaube, das ist ein sehr...
Ja, Saves da hat keiner angerufen. Das funktioniert nicht. Dann kommen wir zurück zu, wo waren wir elektromechanisch? Du weißt schon.
Genau, wir waren bei den elektromechanischen Zylindern, wo viele Hersteller ja immer sagen, sie haben elektromechanische Systeme, aber es ist ja eigentlich nur ein mechanischer Zylinder und ein Doppelknaufzylinder. Und bei diesem Thema Doppelknaufzylinder sind wir ja schon in der Richtung, die Henrikfachgebiet ist. Also so Transponder, Zutrittskontrollsysteme.
Genau, also das gibt es dann auch gerne mal komplett ohne mechanischen Teil oder zumindest ohne mechanischen Teil, die der Benutzer in der Hand hält. Ich weiß nicht, sollen wir Firmennamen nennen?
Weiß ich nicht. Also wenn ich jetzt sag so, also jetzt weiß ich so, Firma Schneiderheit ist total unsicher, kann man super einbrechen. Das sind so Sachen, die wir vielleicht nicht sagen.
Also es gibt da halt viele Anbieter und viele Anbieter haben viele Dinge im Programm. Aber was so am bekanntesten ist, Simmons Foss hat solche Transponder, wo man halt wirklich bloß von außen so einen Knauf sieht. Man hält dann seinen, na das sieht so aus wie so ein kleines 3 cm großes UFO.
Kenn ich, das sieht so wie so ein Einkaufswagenchiphalter.
Also kommt auch an, welcher Einkaufswagenchiphalter du kennst. Wahrscheinlich. Also man hält halt so ein komisches, etwas dickes Ding gegen den Türknauf und dann piept der oder leuchtet und oder beides und dann kann man den drehen für drei Sekunden oder wie lang auch immer.
Wobei das schon eine kleine Besonderheit ist, weil Simons und Foster einen Aktiv-Transponder verwendet. Dieser Transponder hat eine kleine Batterie und funktioniert nur, wenn man einen Knopf drückt. Hat aber den Vorteil, dass sie dadurch eine sehr große Sendereichweite haben. Also sehr groß heißt in dem Fall so einen Meter.
Das heißt du kannst die Tür aufmachen, während du auf die Tür zuläufst.
Genau. Oder so aus der Hosentasche, was so gemessen an anderen Systemen schon eine sehr große Entfernung ist.
Ein Freund von mir hat einen BMW, du kennst schon, der hat einen Schlüssel, der schließt das Auto auf, wenn er sich dem Wagen nähert. Das finde ich total gruselig, weil das kann doch nicht, also das kann doch nicht sicher sein.
Ja, ich finde solche Systeme auch immer. Ich sage dann immer gerne mutig dazu. Also die Verschlüsselung selbst, wenn die Verschlüsselung, die ganzen Funkprotokolle selber brauchbar sind, kann man bei allen kontaktlosen Systemen immer einen sogenannten Relay-Angriff machen oder ein Schwarzes Loch oder Wurmloch, wie auch immer man das nennen möchte, dass man also im Wesentlichen die Reichweite künstlich vergrößert. Man hat halt irgendwie einen Komplizen, der an demjenigen, der den Schlüssel ist, hat und geht dann selber an das Auto und baut zwischen den beiden Dingen eine Weiterleitung auf, die quasi in beiden Richtungen immer weiterleitet. Und wenn der Schlüssel, den der rechtmäßige Inhaber in der Hosentasche hat, halt so eine Reichweite von drei Metern hat, dann ist es natürlich wesentlich einfacher, für den Komplizen da ranzukommen, in Reichweite zu kommen.
Wie macht der Schlüssel das denn in der Hosentasche an? Sendet der die ganze Zeit vor sich hin?
Diese sogenannten Kieles Entriesysteme, da gab es kürzlich eine Untersuchung der ETH Zürich, die haben sich das mal angeguckt und die verwenden in der Regel tatsächlich mehrere unterschiedliche Frequenzsysteme, wo ich glaube das Auto ständig sendet, der Schlüssel dann nur relativ wenig Strom braucht und festzustellen, dass er in der Nähe ist und dann auf eine andere Frequenz antwortet, wo dann die Reichweite und der Stromverbrauch anders ist, aber erst losgeht, wenn er wirklich benötigt wird. Und die haben halt festgestellt, dass diese Rückrichtung vom Schlüssel zum Auto, wenn ich jetzt nicht falsch rum erzähle, aber egal, es stimmt trotzdem, dass diese Rückrichtung halt wesentlich größere Reichweite hat. Also das vom Auto ausgehende hat so was wie drei Meter. Der Schlüssel hat halt 100 Meter. Und dann haben sie halt so Angriffe demonstriert, wo sie dann diese Weiterleitung nur in einer Richtung machen müssen. Die müssen also nicht irgendwie diesen ganzen Kram mit hoher Geschwindigkeit in beiden Richtungen weiterleiten, sondern leiten bloß das Signal vom Auto zum Schlüssel weiter. Während, also die Angriffsvariante war dann zum Beispiel Parkplatz-Einkaufszentrum. Hast du wahrscheinlich so 100 Meter bestimmt nicht mal überbrückt. Und du gehst halt mit deinem Empfänger, also der Angreifer geht mit seinem Empfänger ans Auto. Der Komplizige geht mit dem passenden Sender dazu. An den Menschen mit dem Schlüssel. Und der Schlüssel fängt dann an zu senden, das Auto empfängt das und geht auf. Und die haben halt, ich fand dieses Pfeffer vor allen Dingen deswegen so schön, weil ich da zum ersten Mal wirklich plastisch gelernt habe, wie das mit der Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist. Stellt sich raus, Licht ist in Kupfer sehr langsam. Denn diese Weiterleitung halt probiert und wollten möglichst wenig Verzögerung haben, von einem Ende zum anderen. Und stellt sich raus, die Lichtgeschwindigkeit in Kupfer ist nur 66 Prozent von der in Luft. Das heißt, sie haben also zwei Weiterleitungen gebaut, eine mit einem Kupferkabel dazwischen und eine mit einer Funkstrecke dazwischen. Und die Funkstrecke war schneller. Ist nicht nur für den Angreifer einfacher, sondern auch schneller. Kabel legen ist so doof.
Ist das gleichzeitig, weißt du ob das gleichzeitig auch die Wegfahrsperre ist oder ist das noch ein Ding?
Kommt drauf an, da gibt es unterschiedliche. Die Wegfahrsperre ist dann teilweise integriert, aber halt auf diese anderen, auf diese niedrigen Frequenz, die nur geringe Reichweite hat. Aber die Autos, also ich bin schon mal mit so einem gefahren und das fuhr halt auch los, wenn man mit dem Ding dann eingestiegen ist.
Wie regelt der das? Also kommt da noch irgendwie ein zweites Signal, dass die Wegfahrsperre permanent deaktiviert oder sowas? Also das wäre schlau.
Nee, ich glaube, die ist halt wirklich nur so lange das Ding im Innenaushalt. Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist wahrscheinlich auch sehr herstellerabhängig. Es ist auf jeden Fall, selbst wenn die Kryptographie sicher ist, ist es schon mal vom Prinzip her problematisch.
Wir wissen nicht alles, aber vielleicht wisst ihr was. 0331 70 97 110. Falls ihr was zu sagen habt, werdet ihr auch gehört. Schön formuliert, oder?
Also wir hatten ja jetzt gerade schon selbst, wenn die Verschlüsselung gut sei bei den Autos, das setzt natürlich erst mal voraus, dass wir eine gute Verschlüsselung haben. Dazu kommen wir aber glaube ich später. Ich glaube, wir schieben erst mal noch Simon ein, denn auch wenn man eine gute Verschlüsselung hat, bringt das ja jetzt nicht so viel, wenn man damit an seiner Haustür nur den Schnapper ansteuert, der normalerweise halt die Haustür und nicht die Wohnungstür sichert.
Es fühlt sich aber geil an.
Ja, genau, man geht auf die Tür zu, sie summt und man geht rein, aber die Tür ist sehr streng zugezogen.
Das ist ein Star Trek Ding.
Genau.
Du kannst ruhig sagen, dass du mich für ein armes Schwein hälst.
Also man kann den Teil, der da den Funk macht, auch sicher implementieren, aber wenn es halt nur den Schnapper ansteuert, ist das halt das Gesamtsystem.
Insgesamt ein bisschen lame.
Ja, die Tür ist dann halt so sicher wie eine zugezogene Tür.
Wie hieß das, eine zugezogene Tür ist eine offene Tür, oder?
Eine zugezogene Tür ist eine relativ offene Tür.
Moment, meinen Eltern haben sie aber so eine Tür verkauft, wenn du die zuziehst, dann macht es irgendwie, dann hört sich das so an, als würden 27 Haken irgendwo einschlagen.
Ja, das ist was anderes.
Es gibt selbst verriegelnde Schlösser, die haben, also wenn man sich so die Stirnseite der Tür anguckt, dann gibt es ja dann den Riegel, der rauskommt und oben das schräge ist die Falle. Und der gibt es zwischen den beiden in der Regel, manchmal auch darüber, aber meistens zwischen den beiden, noch eine ganz kleine Falle, eine sogenannte Steuerfalle und wenn die Tür zugeht, dann wird die eingedrückt und dann springt der Riegel raus. So, das passiert in der Regel mechanisch, also wenn man den Drücker runter drückt oder die Tür aufschließt, dann wird eine Feder vorgespannt und wenn die kleine Steuerfalle eingedrückt wird, springt der Riegel aus.
So hört sich das so an, als würde da ein Riegel, also mehrere Riegel rausspringen sogar.
Auch das gibt es ja. Es gibt auch Mehrfachverriegelungen, also wo an mehreren Punkten der Tür dann Riegel rauskommen.
Aber das ist dann halt nicht mehr nur Schnapper.
Das zu kombinieren mit einer Zutrittskontrolle ist schon etwas komplizierter, weil da braucht man dann sehr viel Elektronik und ja auch einen Motor, der den Riegel entführt.
Du brauchst relativ viel mechanische Energie dafür. Das merke ich halt auch, wenn ich bei meinen Eltern die Tür aufschließe, ich muss schon ordentlich drehen.
Also wir haben das in der Uni an einigen Computerräumen und man kann das mit dem Schlüssel schließen, aber das ist halt doof, weil man muss da wirklich stark drehen, sondern man nimmt einfach die Karte und dann bewegt sich halt durch einen Motor, der das gleiche als wenn man aufgeschlossen hätte.
Genau und relativ viel Energie heißt auch viel Stromverbrauch. So eine Schließsysteme oder so eine Motorschlösser oder angetriebene Systeme, Motorzylindern, die sind dann in der Regel verkabelt, also haben einen festen Stromanschluss und da wird es dann wieder mit der Installation sehr aufwendig. Wenn es nicht von Anfang an geplant ist und so eine Tür mit so einem Leerrohr oder schon einem verlegten Kabel vorgerüstet ist, dann bedeutet das einfach, dass man entweder einen hässlichen Kanal auf die Tür klebt oder dass man, was nicht ganz so trivial ist, durch die ganze Tür einbohrt. Das muss dann auch echt gerade sein. Die ist sonst kaputt die Tür.
Dann hat man genug, sich eine neue Tür zu holen, in der das dann ordentlich verkabelt wird.
Das sind halt so Sachen, die in einem finanziellen Bereich die man nicht so ganz mit links schwenkt, also stemmt. Also im privaten Bereich ist das eine Hausnummer, die schon kaum jemand mehr eingeht.
Was würde außerdem passieren, wenn der Strom ausfällt?
Kannst du mal noch einen mechanischen Schlüssel benutzen? Musst halt das einen haben, der nicht drinnen ist. Genau wie beim Auto.
Aber es bleibt dann zu. Ich mein mich daran zu erinnern, mein Vater hatte mal irgendwie ein Problem mit seiner Zentralverriegelung vor 20 Jahren an seinem alten Ford. Da war die Batterie leer, da ist das Auto aufgegangen. Also es ja irgendwie auch ein bisschen scheiße ist.
Eingangs haben wir über, da hat Hendrik die Türöffner, also diese klassischen Fallen, die nach Hauseingangstüren angesprochen. Da gibt es zwei unterschiedliche Prinzipien. Ruhestrom-Türöffner und Arbeitssturm-Türöffner. Der eine bekommt halt nur Strom, um frei zu geben, und der andere steht die ganze Zeit unter Strom, um festzuhalten. Also meistens sind die für beide Einsatzzwecke nutzbar, weil manchmal will man ja auch, dass im Fall eines Stromausfalls auch alle rauskommen. Also es kommt ja immer auf das Szenario an. Also es hat beides eine Berechtigung.
Genau, beim Auto jetzt vielleicht nicht so sehr im Fall eines Stromausfalls, aber gut, dann geht das Auto eh nicht mehr.
Stimmt auch, aber man kann es immer noch anschieben. Worüber amüsierst du dich da eigentlich die ganze Zeit?
Ich musste vorhin auch bloß bei der Steuerfalle mehr so ans Finanzamt denken.
Was Hendrik macht, ist er amüsiert sich immer und muss husten. Und ich versuche immer rauszukriegen, hustet er jetzt oder lacht er?
Meistens huste ich glaube ich. Genau, wir hatten jetzt also kurz angesprochen, Motorschloss, solche tollen selbst schließenden Schlösser, selbst verriegelnden Schlösser, Entschuldigung, ich bin nicht in der Materie drin. Da muss man das alles ordentlich verkabeln, das wird dann teuer. Man will dann auch die Elektronik, die dauernd Strom haben muss, sonst geht das halt nur noch mechanisch drin haben.
Also zu den motorischen Schlössern, da gibt es im Prinzip zwei richtige Motoransätze in der Tür. Das eine ist ein Einsteckschloss, also was ja in der Tür drin steckt, was motorisch ist. Und die zweite Variante ist ein Motorzylinder, wo dann auf der Innenseite ein meist sehr großer motorisch angetriebener Knauf ist, der dann so aufschließt, als ob jemand drehen würde.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit Grillmotor-Bilder im Kopf, ich weiß auch nicht warum.
So dann die Zwischensache ist, dass man ein mechanisches, selbst verregelndes Einsteckschloss benutzt. Also was, wenn man die Tür zuzieht, so wie bei deinen Eltern, klackmacht und verriegelt ist und dann gibt es eine Sonderform, die in dem Riegel, der rausspringt, einen Entriegelungspunkt hat. So und auf der Seite, wo der elektronische Öffner sitzt, der oben die an der Falle dran ist, ist dann ein Riegel, der, wenn man...
Ein Gegenriegel sozusagen, ja?
Nein, ein Gegenriegel, genau.
Ja, ein Riegel, der einen Riegel schiebt.
Ein Riegel, der einen Riegel schiebt, genau. Der hat da so einen kleinen Punkt, den muss er drücken, dann wird der Riegel in dem Schloss freigegeben und dann kann der den von außen so zurückschieben. Das hat den charmanten Vorteil, dass man nicht durch die ganze Tür ein Kabel legen muss, sondern dass alle elektronischen Komponenten auf der Rahmenseite sind. Und so gerade bei Hauseingangstüren hat man ja an der Stelle schon den Strom zu liegen. Eher so praktisch im Nachrüstbereich. Also so Motorschlösser findet man in der Regel in von Anfang an geplanten Sicherheitstüren.
Ich kenne das vor allen Dingen aus der Uni. Das ist 1998 das Gebäude, glaube ich, eröffnet worden und ist dann so geplant gewesen mit allem Drum und Dran. Eine große Glasscheibe in der Tür, die damit gesichert ist und das elektronische System, das damit verbunden ist, war dann auch nicht so der Renner, aber die Mechanik war okay. Genau, das bringt uns dann, glaube ich, oder will Simon noch irgendwelche Dinge einwerfen?
Also endlich war das so die perfekte Überleitung zu der Anstörung.
Genau, also aus meiner Sicht brauche ich ja eigentlich, aus meiner Sicht ist ja der ganze Aktorenkram egal, dass ich gebe irgendwie eine Berechtigung raus, dass ich gebe irgendwie ein Signal raus, jetzt steht der prächtigte Benutzer vor der Tür. Also am häufigsten, also ich würde jetzt, schwierig, ich kenne keine Zahlen, aber ich würde jetzt behaupten, der häufigste Teil ist tatsächlich mit irgendwelchen flachen Karten, so Kreditkarten größer. Die kennst du, hast du jetzt eingangs nicht erwähnt, dass du das viel kennst. Das liegt vermutlich daran, dass sowas unglaublich oft im Firmenkontext vorkommt.
Na witzigerweise, in dem Moment, wo du es sagst, fällt mir ein, ich bin Kunde bei Car2Go und DriveNow.
Zum Beispiel.
Und hab genau das. Also ich hab bei dem einen, die haben so eine komplette Checkkarte, die anderen kleben dir eben so einen Transponder auf den Führerschein.
Genau, die müssen uns noch mal angucken, aber ja, das ist ziemlich genau das gleiche.
Willst du haben oder nimmst du es dann auseinander? Also willst du nur gucken oder nimmst du?
Ja, machen wir noch mal irgendwann anders. Also der größte Teil ist halt tatsächlich im Firmenkontext, gerade aus diesen Gründen, was ich erwähnt habe, dass man da irgendwie einfach Kartenberechtigung und Berechtigung wieder entziehen kann, dass man nicht anfangen muss, Schlösser umzubauen, sondern einfach an irgendeiner Zentralesaal, Mitarbeiter so und so hat jetzt Zugriff auf die Tür so und so, im besten Fall. Und da gibt es halt schon seit vielen Jahren unglaublich viele Firmen und die meisten, unglaublich viele Systeme und die meisten davon sind kaputt. Also mein Einstieg darin war, ich weiß das ja jetzt nicht mehr, weiß hier noch jemand, wann Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in Deutschland war? Also mein erster Vortrag dazu auf dem Chaos Communication Kongress, mein Einstieg darin war im Wesentlichen, dass ich mir das System der Uni angeguckt habe, was ich schon erwähnt habe. Das war ein System der Firma NEDAP, was einfach einfach bloß eine blanke Karte war.
Warte, den Namen kenn ich irgendwo her.
Ja, ja, genau. Die bauen Dinge. Also neue Dinge vielleicht auch sicherer.
Das war ja mit dem Wahlcomputer, das war doch NEDAP, ne?
Netherlands Apparat, Fabrik oder so ähnlich. Ich kann den niederländischen Einwurf da nicht. Aber genau, die bestellen halt so was her. Und man hatte so eine weiße Karte. Und an der Tür war irgendwie so eine flache Stelle, die entweder grün oder rot leuchtete. Man hielt die Karte davor und dann ging der Motor los. Und die Tür geht auf. Da hatte ich keine größere Ahnung davon, aber es kam mir schon ein bisschen unsicher vor. Das ging relativ schnell, wenn man die Karte davor hält, bis es losging. Da konnte nicht so besonders viel passieren, dachte ich mir so. Ich hatte mir das dann angeguckt. Ich hatte keine Ahnung davon. Ich bin dann so richtig mit dem elektronischen Vorschlagkamera drauf losgegangen, mit dem USRP.
Mit dem was?
USRP, Universal Software Radio, Unified, EU irgendwas Software Radio. Software Defined Radio ist also ein Funkempfänger, der im Wesentlichen einfach, man stellt mehr oder weniger den Frequenzbereich ein und empfängt dann einfach alles. Und sortiert dann den Rest in Software aus, sodass man also nicht anfangen muss, wenn man irgendwelche Funkempfänger baut, an Hardware rumzulöten, sondern man nimmt sich einfach so ein Stückchen Funkspektrum in den Rechner und überführt dann alle möglichen Funkprobleme in Softwareprobleme. Das kostet halt relativ viel, wenn man das in dieser großen Variante haben will, gibt es auch wesentlich günstiger, hatte ich damals nicht gewusst, dass es auch einfacher gegangen wäre. Hab es mir also so angeguckt, so Antenne rangehalten, Karte vorgehalten, geguckt, was passiert. Und dann stellt sich raus, es ist ein sehr einfaches System gewesen, sobald, also aus der Tür kommt einfach bloß ein Funkfeld, elektromagnetisches Wechselfeld, und sobald man die Karte ranhält, fängt ihr an, ihre Identitätsnummer zu senden. Also wenn man sich das, das Prinzip nennt sich induktiv gekoppelt, wenn man sich das vorstellen möchte, funktioniert das wie ein Transformator, das hat man vielleicht mal im Physikunterricht gehabt. So irgendwie so eine Privémerwindung, eine Sekundärwindung gibt und wenn man auf der einen Wechselstrom anlegt, kommt auf der anderen Wechselspannung raus. Genauso funktioniert das mit solchen kontaktlosen Karten, bloß dass halt die Sekundärspule jetzt nicht fest eingebaut ist, sondern in der Karte drin ist. Wenn ich also die Karte vor die andere Spule halte, kriegt die Karte durch dieses Feld Strom, kann also irgendwelche Dinge machen, ist dann ein kleiner Chip drin, der dann mehr oder weniger intelligente Dinge tut und um zurück zu senden, ändert die Karte einfach ihren Stromverbrauch. Das ist eine sehr coole Sache. Das Lastmulation nennt sich das. Die hat also im Wesentlichen Widerstand, den sie ein- und ausschaltet. Das macht dann eine Rückwirkung auf die Primärspule, auf die Senderspule.
Aber woher weiß die Karte, wann sie ein- und ausgeschaltet hat? Oder macht sie das in dem Moment, wo Strom kommt?
Na, sobald Strom kommt, ist die Karte erst mal an, hat also Strom, wie jeder andere Computer auch, kann dann irgendwelche Berechnungen durchführen, wie jeder andere Computer auch, und kann sich dann irgendwann entscheiden, jetzt betätige ich mal den Sender. Diese einfachen Karten, so Mitte der 90er, ich würde eher sagen Technik der 80er, man hat ja an der Uni dann wahrscheinlich nicht immer das Letzte, Neueste und Teuerste. Also diese war halt so gebaut, dass sie einfach anfängt, in einer Schleife hintereinander weg, eine Nummer zu senden, sobald sie Strom bekommt. Und ich hab dann auch, ja, aus der Nummer selber konnte ich nicht so viel rausschließen, also ich hab mich für verschiedene Karten angeguckt, konnte nicht so richtig herausfinden, wie jetzt diese Nummer, die gesendet wird, mit der Aufgedrucktenummer zusammenhängt, aber war egal, solange ich bloß ne Kopie machen möchte. Ich hab dann also einfach, ich hab auch festgestellt, dass das Datensignal mit einer sehr niedrigen Frequenz ist. Also die Datenrate war glaube ich zwei oder vier Kilohertz für Leute, die Audio, das ist so tiefer Sprachbereich. Das ist also irgendwas, was mit jedem Audiogerät noch geht. Dann hab ich mir gedacht, ich hab so ein iPod drum liegen. Hab also so ein Lastmodulation, das ist ja das Sendeprinzip, also so ein Lastmodulationssender gebaut, der sich an den Kopfhörerausgang meines iPods anschließt. Das Datensignal als Audiodatei auf mein iPod getan. Dann diese Pappe, wo ich die Schaltung draufgebaut habe, an die Tür gehalten, eine auf dem iPod auf Play gedrückt und kleinen Schrecken kriegt, als sich der Motor in Bewegung setzte. Also das war dann schon, ja, ging dann. Das war dann auch mein erster Kongressvortrag. Später habe ich festgestellt, wenn man mal so in die Vergangenheit zurückguckt, das Signal ist Lastenmulation, aber es ist ein wesentlichen Amplitudemulation. Wenn man sich an seinen Großvater, oder mittlerweile vielleicht Großvater erinnert, wie der in den 20ern Radio gehört hat, das war auch Amplitudemulation mit dem Detektorradio. Habe ich also einen Detektorempfänger gebaut, ist genauso oder sogar noch einfacher. Man nimmt halt einfach eine Diode als Empfänger, eine Diode und eine Antenne, mehr braucht man nicht, und stellt sich raus, da kommt dann halt einfach das Datensignal raus. Wenn ich also meine Empfängerschaltung, eine gültige Karte und eine gültige Tarte an die Tür hänge, kommt da einfach als Audiosignal raus. Ich habe dann also einfach mit meinem iPod kann man auch aufzeichnen, habe also einfach das Signal aufgezeichnet und später wieder gespielt, abgespielt und die Tür geht auf.
Das hat dann so ein bisschen was, was war denn das?
WarGames.
WarGames war das mit dem Kassettenrecorder.
Genau, ich habe das mit dem Kassettenrecorder probiert, das ging leider nicht, der hat zu stark gerauscht, aber prinzipiell würde es auch gehen.
Ich hatte gedacht, das wäre irgendwie nur fake, dann war das echt.
Ja, ja, nein, nein.
Darum findet ihr Hacker diesen Film auch so gut, ne?
Ja, der war nicht unterhaltsam, durchweg unterhalten, wie ein Freund von mir immer sagt. Und diese einfachen Systeme, das ist halt nicht nur in jeder, da ist ein anderes System wesentlich weiterverbreitet, veriChip, das kennt man vielleicht, wenn man Haustiere hat und damit in Europa rumreist, damit werden also, das wird also den Tieren unter die Haut injiziert, das ist so ein kleines Glasrührchen und da wird dann irgendwo in der Datenbank aufgeschrieben, welche Impfung das Tier schon gekriegt hat und dann darf man halt in Europa reisen, irgendwie sowas. Und das ist halt genauso so ein System, kriegt halt Strom und fängt an, eine ID zu senden.
Gab es auch als Eintrittskarte in irgendeiner Disko?
Genau und dann gab es halt wiederum sehr mutig bezeichnende Leute, die irgendwo in einem Club als Zahlungsmedium eingebaut haben. Ich hab mich auch sehr amüsiert. Es gab irgendwo mal einen Artikel über eine Sicherheitsfirma, die irgendwas mit Internetsicherheit gemacht hat und die halt auch damit geworben haben, dass sie für ihre kritischen Räume an manchen Stellen die Mitarbeiter so ein Ding unter die Haut gekriegt haben. Der Witz ist halt, dass das nicht schwerer nachzumachen ist. Also es gab da, das war das nächste, es gibt ein Werkzeug, das nennt sich Proxmark.
Das Sicherheitsfeature ist also, kann man nicht verlieren, weil es unter der Haut.
Genau.
Kein Sicherheitsfeature, das ist ein praktisch Sicherheitsfeature. Ein Organisationsfeature.
Das fühlt jetzt auf ein gewisses Sicherheitsgebot.
Im Deutschen ist es doof, dass das Wort Sicherheit zwei Bedeutungen hat. Auf Englisch ist das einfacher, es gibt halt Safety und Security. Ja, genau.
Dann müssen wir ein Wort finden.
Ja, erfinden mal ein Wort. Gibt es vielleicht Vorschläge von Zuschauern? Erfindet mal ein Wort. Ein einfaches Werkzeug, um solche Systeme anzugucken, so ein Forschungswerkzeug, das anschließend das Verbreiteste wurde, ist der Proxmark von Jonathan Westhues, glaube ich. Der hat auch ungefähr 2006 mal für Wired mit Annaline Navitz, glaube ich, sich so ein Wehrichip angeguckt. Hatte auch keine Ahnung, was das ist. Er hat dieses Tool gebaut, um andere Dinge anzugucken. Dann kam halt die Redakteurin zu ihm und hat hier, guck mal, ich habe da so ein Ding da. Und da haben sie sich wohl im Café getroffen. Es gibt auf seiner Webseite so einen schönen Beitrag. Er hat sich das angeguckt. Er ist nicht genau das, was ich schon habe, aber ich ändere mal da die Frequenz und hier und da. Und dann hat er ja nachmittags halt eine fertige Kopie gehabt, mehr oder weniger, die dann auch mit dem Lesegerät funktionierte. Also diese Dinge sind nur deswegen nicht in rauen Maßen umgangen und gebrochen, weil halt die Lesereichweite dieser kleinen Antennen so unglaublich gering ist. Also bei diesen Haustierviechern muss man halt mit dem Lesegerät mehr oder weniger das Tier belästigen und die richtige Stelle finden, so ranhalten.
Aber wir werden doch vermutlich früher oder später irgendwo ankommen, wo wir solche Teile haben, die entsprechend Reichweite haben und das wird uns als Komfortmerkmal verkaufen.
Ja, das war auch bei dem NEDAP-System so. Da habe ich auch sehr gestaunt. Ich habe später gehört, dass die tatsächlich so als Komfortmerkmal ein Lesegerät verkaufen mit drei Meter Reichweite, dass die Tür schon, also Hands-free Operation, dass die Tür schon aufgeht, wenn man drauf zugeht, was halt bei so einem System, wo es so einfach zu kopieren ist, mutig, sage ich wieder.
Big,, Hier ist. Chaosradio 186, Fritz ist an. Irgendwer hat mir, was heißt Irgendwer, Frau von Hempel hat mich auf Twitter angehauen. Sagt, die 90er hätten angerufen, wollten ihr Soundbett wieder haben. Na warte, nächstes Mal gibt's wirklich was aus den 90ern. Könnte mal gucken.
Cotny Joe oder so?
Und zwar ja, genau im Loop. Ich will einen Cotny Joe Loop und zwar aber gar nicht den ganzen Song, sondern nur Ding.
Naja, wir waren also bei nur ID-basierten kontaktlosen Zugangskontrollsystemen. WRI-Chip ist da so der verbreitetste Haustierbereich. Für tatsächlich Anführungszeichen Sicherheit, Anführungszeichen Anwendung gibt es da auch unglaublich viele Systeme. Die laufen häufig unter dem Namen EM4100 irgendwas. Die sind aber auch alle so gebaut, dass im Wesentlichen nur eine ID gesendet wird, sobald das Lesegerät rankommt. Manchmal ist der Chip sogar so schlau, dass er eine neue ID gesetzt bekommen kann. Aber das war es dann schon. Da ist nichts mit Sicherheit, wie ich sie als Informatiker interpretieren würde gemeint. Ein Bekannter von mir formuliert das mal sehr schön. Firmenname ist dafür da, dass die Tür aufgeht, wenn jemand Berechtigtes davor steht. So der andere Fall ist nicht so unser Ding.
Das heißt aber doch gleich...
Wenn jemand Berechtigtes davor steht, geht die Tür auf. Der Umkehrfall geht vielleicht auch auf, ist egal. Hauptsache in dem anderen Fall.
Bleibt möglicherweise zu.
Vielleicht. Kommt darauf an, wie dämlich sich der Angreifer anstellt. Bei diesem EM4000 gab es dann eine große Gruppe von Chips von der Firma. Mittlerweile heißt die NXP, früher war es Philips Semiconductors, noch früher war es Philips, das ändert sich ab und zu mal. Die haben eine Chipreihe namens Hightech, die ist tatsächlich programmierbar. Also die haben rudimentäre Sicherheitsfunktionen. Man hat da irgendwie vier mal zwölf Byte Speicher oder so und kann aber da drin Daten ablegen und dann einfach in der Konfiguration einstellen, sende diese Daten einfach sobald du Strom kriegst. Also beide Varianten. Und den kann man dann praktischerweise, das hat dann Jonathan Westhues auch vorgeführt, ne Moment, Entschuldigung, das war aus Air of Idiot, das war Adam Laurie glaube ich, der hat dann halt vorgeführt, dass man diese neuen Chips einfach programmieren kann und sagen kann, hier hast du die Nummer von dem Chip aus dem anderen System, spiel die einfach mal ab, sobald du Strom kriegst. Das funktioniert dann auch sehr gut und manche Firmen kann man damit noch beeindrucken, das ist richtig.
Immer noch?
Jaja, also ich habe tatsächlich, ich habe damit beruflich so ein bisschen zu tun und es gibt halt Kunden, die sowas noch als Altsystem rumliegen haben und dann leichte Probleme haben, weil es keinen mehr gibt, der die Karten herstellt.
Okay, das liegt dann aber daran, dass die einfach ihren Kram nicht mal ausgetauscht haben, aber die Hersteller produzieren mittlerweile besser. Du siehst nicht so aus, als wenn die Hersteller mittlerweile besser was anproduzieren.
Also ich glaube, so langsam können wir mal zu My Fair Classic kommen, das ist so ungefähr der größte, den ich mir dann danach angeguckt habe mit Freunden. Das war dann wahrscheinlich 2007. Also My Fair Classic ist so, das ist der Marktführer, was kontaktlose Karten mit irgendwelchen einfachen Sicherheitsfunktionen angibt. Die hatten damals nach Eigenauskunft so was wie 1, 5 Milliarden verkaufte Karten und 50.000, 100.000, 500.000, ich weiß die so in der Größenordnung Lesegeräte. Mittlerweile haben sie wohl das Problem, dass sie an die Karten haben eine Nummer, die nur bis 4 Milliarden 300 ein bisschen was geht. Die haben sie jetzt wohl mittlerweile ausgeschöpft.
Das heißt, dass sie viel wieder auf unserem Schlüssel auf dem Schrottplatz sammeln.
Ja, ich glaube, sie stellen sie dann einfach nicht mehr her, bzw. haben jetzt die Nummer verlängert, was dann natürlich mit den alten Systemen auch nicht mehr geht. Und die waren halt so unglaublich verbreitet, sind also unter ihrem eigenen Erfolg gelitten. Die Firma selber hat das nie wirklich als Sicherheitsprodukt betrachtet. Aber war halt bei so, man muss sich das so vorstellen, es gibt halt diese Firma, die stellt den Chip her. Die stellen halt nur Hype-Leiter her. Da ist nicht mal ein Gehäuse drumrum im Normalfall. Und dann werden die verkauft, dann gibt es eine Firma, die stellt z.B. Karten her. Und dann werden die Karten verkauft, und dann gibt es eine Firma, die stellt Türschlösser her. Und dann werden die verkauft an eine Firma, die Türschlösser einbaut. Und das ist dann gegebenenfalls noch eine Firma, die selber irgendwas betreibt. Man hat also so was wie vier, fünf Hierarchie-Ebenen dazwischen. Und von dem Hersteller des Chips bis zu dem Anwender geht dann meistens dieses, die Karten sind übrigens nicht sicher, ein bisschen verloren. Das ist jedenfalls nicht so. Also wenn man sich das angeguckt hat, ein wichtiges Prinzip, was man Computer-Sicherheit immer beachten sollte, Security by obscurity funktioniert nicht. Das muss man vielen Leuten immer wieder einprügeln.
Obwohl hat das nicht eine Zeit lang bei den Telefonkarten ganz gut funktioniert? Nein, das war anders mit den Telefonkarten. Ja, ja, das war dann noch...
Ja, so erhängte Leute und so. Das ist eine andere Art von Security, glaube ich. Das nennt man bei der Kryptographie Rubber-Hose-Kryptographie. Anderes Thema. Ne, also MyFair Classic war halt deswegen, bis es aus den 90ern entstanden, so ungefähr 94 entwickelt worden von der Firma Micron, Micron Technik für Sonnstars, integrierte Mikrosysteme oder irgendwie so was. In der Schweiz, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, steht alles in meiner Gplume, aber das hab ich alles schon wieder vergessen. Also so ungefähr 94 entwickelt worden, hat er halt ein proprietäres Verschlüsselungssystem. Das heißt schon mal nichts Gutes, wenn man sich damit auskennt. Und das war noch eine 48-Bit Schifre. Wenn man also jetzt irgendwie die Schlüssellängen ankommt, guckt so 94, reicht das vielleicht aus. Aber heute rechnet man halt 48 Bit auf einer normalen, durchschnittlichen Spielemaschine am Wochenende durch. Und es war halt irgendwann selbst gebastelt. Es war eine Stromschifre. Stromschifferen sind jetzt nicht dafür bekannt, besonders einfach zu implementieren oder zu entwickeln zu sein. Geht meistens schief.
Was ist eine Stromschifre? Das hat jetzt nichts mit elektrischem Strom zu tun.
Ich bin gerade auf die Schifre. Der Unterschied bei Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen ist, bei symmetrischen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, ist es nach Strom und nach Blockschifren. Eine Stromschifre verschlüsselt einfach jedes Bit, ein Bit nach dem anderen. Man kann also beliebig viele Bits, auch ungerade Anzahlen, reintun. Eine Blockschifre verschlüsselt immer einen ganzen Block, zum Beispiel immer acht Byte am Stück oder immer 16 Byte am Stück. Was dann doof ist, wenn man nur drei Byte verschlüsseln will, dann muss man es hinten irgendwie auffüllen. Aber dafür ist es wesentlich häufiger nicht total kaputt. Ja, und Mifare Classic war halt nur deswegen, also allein diese 48 Bytes sind halt, wie gesagt, etwas lächerlich, nur deswegen noch als sicher betrachtet, weil es keine Implementierung davon gab. Also diese Firma hat halt die Chips verkauft, die in die Karten kommen und die Chips verkauften Lesegeräte kommen. Und auf beiden Seiten ist die Verschlüsselung implementiert. Und niemand sonst kennt den Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus. Bis dahin ja, genau. Niemand sonst. Und wenn man das normal probiert, so eine Karte vor ein Lesegerät zu halten, dann dauert jeder Versuch, sagen wir mal, 5 Millisekunden. Dann ist man halt bei 120, 125, nee, 8 Millisekunden waren es, glaube ich. Dann ist man jedenfalls in der Größenordnung 120 Versuche pro Sekunde. Und dann rechnet man das mal schnell durch und stellt dann fest, naja, um einen Schlüssel auszuprobieren, brauche ich 26.000 Jahre. Und sagt man, okay, ist sicher. Solange jedenfalls keiner das schneller machen kann. Na und was wir halt damals gemacht haben, Carsten Null und Starbuck vom Chaos Computer Club, ich hab mir nur das Funkprotokoll angeguckt, die beiden anderen haben sich die Chips angeguckt. Und das meine ich jetzt durchaus wörtlich. Also Starbuck hat die da aus den Karten extrahiert und dann abgeschliffen und dann guckt man sich halt unter dem Mikroskop an, was der so tut. So ein Mikrochip ist ja auch nichts anderes als eine Leiterplatte. Es sind halt irgendwelche Leiterbahnen und irgendwelche Bauteile mit verbunden sind und wenn man da nur genau genug hinguckt, kann man halt feststellen, wie sie verbunden sind und was sie wahrscheinlich tun. Und so hatten wir dann den Algorithmus rekonstruiert und konnten halt selber das MyFair Classic Protokoll sprechen. Und dann ist man schon mal wesentlich schneller dabei. Und dann gab es noch eine Handvoll Implementierungsfehler. Also die Zufallzahlen waren nicht wirklich zufällig. Und dann fiel das so nach und nach komplett in sich zusammen. Wir haben damals auf unserem Kongressvortrag absichtlich nicht alles veröffentlicht. In normaler Sicherheitsforschung redet man ja von Responsible Disclosure. Dass man also dem Hersteller sagt, hier ich hab was gefunden, ich geb dir 30 Tage Zeit, reparier das mal, bring ein Update raus. Jetzt bei Karten und verbauten Kartendesern ein Update rauszubringen, ist nicht so einfach. Also haben wir halt dem Hersteller nicht vorher Bescheid gesagt und einfach nicht alles veröffentlicht, sondern nur genug, um zu zeigen, dass ein Problem da ist.
Wie hat der Hersteller damals reagiert?
Da muss ich kurz überlegen. Ich glaub, erst waren sie etwas, sie haben es auch irgendwie erst nicht mitgekriegt und dann gab es irgendwelche Pressemitteilungen von wegen, wir werden uns im Sinne unserer Kunden mit den maximalen rechtlichen Mitteln usw. Und dann...
Den Boden erschießen.
Jaja, genau, und dann hat sich jemand vom Chaos Computer Club mit denen getroffen. Ich war vorsichtshalber nicht da und dann verschwand die Pressemitteilung plötzlich. Und ansonsten ist der Hersteller auch sehr zugänglich, wie gesagt, wir haben das selber nie als Sicherheitsprodukt vermarktet und haben allen ihren Großkunden mit denen, also wenn da so ein richtig großer Kunde wie Microsoft bei denen eine Schulung macht, auch immer gesagt, ja keine Sicherheit, aber halt bei solchen kleineren Systemen. Da kommen wir wieder zu meiner Uni. Die hat nämlich, also das alte NEDAP-System ist dann letztes Jahr dann doch mal ausgeführt oder ist schon länger kaputt und ist letztes Jahr wohl komplett die Beine hochgerissen, also haben sie in der Not gedrungen das gleiche eingebaut, was die restliche Uni benutzt. Er stellt sich raus, ist Meifer Classic basierend. Und also was wir halt damals rausgefunden haben, war schon nicht sehr schmeichelhaft für das System, aber...
Naja, was heißt nicht schmeichelhaft? Also es war ja nie als Sicherheitssystem konzipiert.
Aber trotzdem...
Ist ja nicht das Problem des Herstellers.
Genau. Der Angriff, den Karsten und ein Kollege gefunden haben, dauerte glaube ich immer noch so was wie 12 Sekunden. Und auch nur, wenn man die richtigen Daten hat. Stellt sich raus, wir haben ja nicht alles veröffentlicht. Eine indische Forschungsgruppe an der Radbaut-Universität Nijmere hat sich das angeguckt. Die hatten das wohl auch schon mal vorher am Wickel und sind nicht weitergekommen, haben sich dann unsere Teilergebnisse angeguckt und haben den Rest, den wir nicht dazu gesagt haben, noch mal unabhängig von uns entdeckt und haben noch ein bisschen mehr gefunden. Die Karte hatte einen Implementierungsfehler. Normalerweise ist es halt so, dass auf der Karte ein Schlüssel ist und auch im Lesegerät ein Schlüssel. Und die Karte und das Lesegerät reden miteinander und dann wissen sie beide von sich gegenseitig, dass sie den Schlüssel kennen. Und das Lesegerät muss zuerst beweisen, dass sie den Schlüssel kennen, sonst sagt die Karte einfach gar nichts. Es gab einen Implementierungsfehler, als die Karte manchmal doch was gesagt hat. Und man davon dann schon wieder ein Stückchen auf den Schlüssel schließen konnte. Ja, also mit diesem neuen Angriff der Niederländer kann man den Algorithmus in, lass mich lügen, 90 Millisekunden, irgendwie sowas, also Bruchteile von Bruchteilen einer Sekunde brechen und das ist dann auch egal. Und mit dem Implementierungsfehler der Karte kann man das sogar tun, wenn man gar kein Lesegerät hat. Also kein echtes, man hat nur die Karte auf der Straße gefunden.
Die Türen deiner Uni stehen also sperngelweit offen im Prinzip?
Ja, ich hab dann also einfach mal eine meiner Karten, die ich legal habe, warum mich das so genervt hat, ich hab zwei Karten gekriegt. Ich hab eine für die Tür und eine mit einem Chip für den Computer. Und in der Chipkarte ist aber auch ein kontaktloser Chip drin, der ist bloß nicht bespielt und für die Tür freigeschaltet. Also hab ich zum einen mal angeguckt, wie das Ding funktioniert. Sie haben MyFair Classic, sie haben den gleichen Schlüssel für alle Karten. Und dann steht auf der Karte gespeichert, das ist im Datenbereich wirklich nur die aufgedruckte Nummer. Also hab ich das halt auf meiner Chipkarte für den Computer auch gemacht, hab den Schlüssel da eingestellt, die Nummer drauf kopiert und jetzt geht die halt auch.
Weiß deine Uni, dass dieses Problem besteht?
Ja genau, das ist dann der nächste Teil.
Oder erfahren Sie das gerade erst?
Ich hab dann mit dem Leiter der Rechnerbetriebsgruppe bei uns geredet und das Thema war ja neu eingebaut, noch nicht abgenommen usw. Und das ging dann auch zu seinem Lauf. Wie gesagt, da sind immer so mehrere Ebenen dazwischen. Die Firma, die die Schlösser herstellt, ist aus Thüringen, glaube ich. Hab den Namen schon wieder vergessen. Und ich hab natürlich erst mal gemeint, nee, nee, geht gar nicht. So, das ist völlig unmöglich so was. Das kann gar nicht sein. Dann hat der Rechnerbetriebsgruppenleiter mir einfach, sein Sohn arbeitet aber zufällig bei der Verwaltung, das macht sich sehr gut, hat mir einfach zwei Kartennummern aus der Verwaltung genannt. Die habe ich auf Karten geschrieben, die dann in der Verwaltung funktioniert haben. Das ging dann schon mal. Abgenommen haben sie das System trotzdem. Sie überlegen sich dann später nochmal, eine Erweiterung einzubauen, dass es nicht ganz so einfach ist, aber das Grundkonzept bleibt. Ich kann also jetzt jede Tür in der Uni öffnen.
Aber jeder, der das halbwegs verstanden hat, was du gerade erzählt hast, kann auch jede Tür der Uni öffnen.
Ja, wenn ihr die richtige Kartennummer kennt. Notfalls probiert man sie halt durch. Die sind halt der Reihe nach...
Oder man klaut sich eine.
Ja, das wäre ja einfacher. Die sind zum Glück ja aufgedruckt. Man braucht bloß die aufgedruckte Nummer wissen.
Das mit dem Klauen ist ja gerade der Punkt der elektronischen Systeme. Weil die geklaute Karte wird ja dann gemeldet und wird ja dann gesperrt. Also die wird ja aus der Zutrittsberechtigungsliste einfach entfernt. Das ist ja eigentlich der Grund oder einer der Hauptgründe, warum man sich so ein System anschafft.
Genau, deswegen ist es immer schöner, wenn man eine Karte nicht klauen muss, sondern irgendwie anders benutzen kann.
Sondern die, das Schuldirektors einmal ausliest, ohne dass der es mitbekommt.
Genau, wenn man dann ein System hat, was nach Auslesen eine Kopie ermöglicht und nicht nur ordentliche Systeme erlauben, das halt nicht. Da kommen wir aber ganz spät dazu, glaube ich.
Was ich ja jetzt noch gerne wüsste, also wenn die Nummer mit War Games und diesem Tape, wenn die funktioniert, also wenn das tatsächlich geht, was aus den ganzen Agentenfilmen funktioniert denn dann sonst noch? Also da gibt's ja so, weiß ich nicht, also das Absurdeste, was ich mal gesehen hab, das war allerdings in einer Comedy, da hat jemand in ein Röhrchen gehaucht, woraufhin, also Atemkontroll gesteuert, die Tür aufgegangen ist. Das gibt's. Das gibt's? Das war Community, nichts, was in Community hier gezeigt wird, gibt's.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ich glaube, das hat neulich mal, zumindest experimentell gab es solche Systeme. Ja, alles Mögliche. Vieles ist grober Unfug, manches nicht. Ein sehr schöner Film ist zum Beispiel Sneakers, die lautlosen. Da geht es auch um irgendwie so eine schwarze Box, was aus filmtechnischer Sicht ja einfach bloß so das Teil ist, was man haben muss. Ja klar. Was aber, wenn man halt drauf guckt, ja, das ist offensichtlich irgendein System, irgendein Ding, was RSA faktorisiert, worauf halt die meisten asymmetrischen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen basieren. Und wenn es sowas gäbe, wäre es, es ist nicht, mathematisch nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es das gibt leider. Und wenn es sowas gäbe, wäre es halt was tolles. Und solche Dinge gibt es halt in vielen Filmen. Ich glaube, bei dem neuen James Bond, der so komisch aussieht, haben sie auch damit geworben, dass alle Dinge, die er benutzt, in der Realität existieren, diese ganzen Handys und der ganze Kram, das mit dem SIM-Karte kopieren ist nicht ganz so einfach, aber ging früher prinzipiell auch.
Wie hat er das denn gemacht, SIM-Karte kopieren? Hat er die alte überhaupt rausgenommen?
Ja, ich glaube, er hat sie in ein Gerät gesteckt und hat halt ein Handy, was genauso funktioniert. Ich habe gerade erst auf einem Kongressenvortrag gehört, dass es tatsächlich nicht ganz so abwegig ist, dass also, wenn man es tatsächlich hinkriegen kann, ein Handy zweimal einzubuchen unter Umständen und dann Dinge mitkriegt. Aber das war mehr so auf Funk-Ebene, also da braucht man dann die SIM-Karte gegebenenfalls nicht mal für. Und früher konnte man wohl auch SIM-Karten kopieren, das haben sie wohl mittlerweile größtenteils gefixt, da waren also irgendwelche Probleme mit den SIM-Karten.
Aber wo wir gerade bei Abschweifen und Filmen und Aufsperrtechniken waren, also ein absoluter Filmklassiker sind ja diese Kreditcheck-Karten, mit denen man einfach die Tür aufmacht.
Ja, genau.
Das ist total klasse, wenn wir mal so zu Notöffnungen kommen und in der Tür schon so zwei abgebrochene Karten stecken.
Das ist nicht wahr, oder? Das passiert wirklich?
Ja, manchmal auch drei oder vier. Oder völlig zerstörte Personalausweise.
Ja, meiner hat auch leichte Dellen.
Der Personalausweis geht schon, also der alte zumindest, geht schon in die richtige Richtung. Der Hintergrund ist, dass diese Karten einfach viel zu starr sind und nicht um die Ecke des Türfalzes kommen und dann einfach abbrechen.
Ja, aber dann nimmt man doch eine aufgeschnittene Petflasche, oder nicht? Zum Beispiel. Also das weiß ja sogar ich.
Also ich hatte das Problem auch schon mal und ich hatte dann tatsächlich, also mein Personalausweis hat leichte Dellen davon getragen. Mein Problem war nämlich, dass das Loch, in das die Falle fällt, einfach viel zu groß war, dass der Personalausweis drin verschwunden. Das ging dann halt, die erwünschte Hebelwirkung war da nicht da. Ein Freund von mir kam dann einfach vorbei mit so einer Plastedingst und dann war die Tür auch in 30 Sekunden auf ihm.
Ja, ich hab mich mal ausgesperrt. Ja, genau. Da hab ich dann gesehen, also er hat das dann mit so einem komischen Metallteil gemacht und ich dachte, okay, Petflasche aufschneiden, müsste ungefähr denselben Effekt haben.
Also ich hab mir das dann auch irgendwann mal im Köln Kongress mitgenommen. Es gibt solche Öffnungskarten, in denen einfach so Plaste ist mit Metaflon-Beschichtung, dass es auch rutscht und...
Gibt es da eigentlich Fachgeschäfte für, in die man, ich mein, so jemand wie du, der muss doch irgendwo auch einen Großhandel haben, wo...
Richtig, da gibt's Firmen, die sich auf Aufsperrwerkzeug spezialisiert haben. In der Regel verkaufen die Leute nur gegen einen Gewerbeschein. Also man muss halt vorzeigen, dass man ein Gewerbe dafür hat. So ein Gewerbeschein kostet 25 Euro und man kann die Werbe auch gleich wieder abmelden. Dann sieht man ja, mir Werbeschein ja erstmal nicht an. Aber es gibt ja eigentlich eine leichte Kontrolle, aber ich würde auch nicht für jeden Kollegen meine Hand ins Feuer legen, dass er es nicht einfach so weiterverkauft.
Würde man das merken? Nee, das würde niemand merken. Wenn du zwei Dinge im Großhandel kaufst und mir eins verscheuerst, krieg ich ja keiner mit.
Ja, es kann ja auch kaputt sein, oder für einen anderen Mitarbeiter. Ja, kann ja auch ganz trivial sein, dir wird das Auto mit dem Werkzeug geklaut. Also bei uns ist so weit über Nacht nie im Auto, aber kann passieren.
Zurück zur Elektronik.
Machen wir die Klammer wieder zu. Elektronik, genau, nicht Plaste. Also manchmal auch vor allen Dingen Plaste.
Plaste-Elektronik.
Ja, das ist eher bei E-Books der nächste große Renner und Handys, dass man die Displays so aus Plaste macht, damit die nicht aus Glas sind und gleich springen, wenn man sie von der Seite schief anguckt. Es gibt da sehr schöne Demonstrationsvideos, wie jemand so ein Display nimmt und mit dem Hammer draufhaut.
Ah cool, ich kenn das halt von normalen Gehäuse. Ein Freund von mir hat dieses Nokia, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es heißt, der knackt damit immer Nüsse. Allerdings mit der Rückseite. Das sieht sehr spektakulär aus. Das ist halt Polycarbonat. Kannst du halt mitmachen, was du willst. Der arbeitet halt auch bei Nokia und macht dann halt immer einen auf die Kose. Ja, ihr mit euren scheiß iPhones, hast mal eine Walnuss. Klatsch, klatsch, klatsch. Und dann ist halt die Nuss auf. Sehr schön eigentlich.
Also ist es nicht so, als ob ich nicht auch schon eine Flasche mit meinem Telefon offen macht hätte, aber die sehen dann danach auch meistens ziemlich ungünstig aus.
Also da ist halt nichts dran. Ich weiß auch nicht. Ich hab auch schon den Verdacht gehabt, dass der vielleicht irgendwie so einen super geheimen Geheimprototypen hat, um uns alle zu beeindrucken, damit wir dieses scheiß Telefon kaufen. Oh, das war ein Filmhandy. Genau. Aber ich hab damit auch fotografiert. Konnte das überhaupt fotografieren? Das hat sogar so einen ganz creepy Bildstabilisator gehabt. Der meinte, lass mich dir das mal zeigen. Das hier ist die, ich hab einen Kasten Bier drin Variante. Und hat dann das Handy genommen, hat mit dem Ding so hin und her gewackelt, die ganze Zeit und dann einfach auf einen Auslöser gedrückt. Und das Ding hat es geschafft, aus diesem Gewackel ein scharfes Bild zu errechnen. Ich war sehr beeindruckt.
Das ist die Variante, wo Nokia neulich auf die Schnauze geflogen ist, weil sie in der Reflektion einfach, sie haben halt den Bildstabilisator beworben und fuhren halt an einem Geschäft vorbei und in der Reflektion sah man dann halt den Wagen mit dem Stativ von der Kamera.
Na aber das hat also, an dem Handy hat das ganz gut funktioniert. Es ist dann nur so ein komisches Betriebssystem drauf.
Ja.
Aber um mal wieder in den Bogen zu schlagen, es gibt ja auch Handys, mit denen man Türen öffnen kann.
Ja, es gibt auch Leute, die so was machen.
James Bond hatte so eins, mit Elektroschocker drin auch gleichzeitig.
Ja, es gibt da ganz unterschiedliche Sachen. Es gibt Handys, denen ein Transponder integriert ist. Es gibt auch Handys.
Seit fünf Jahren das neue Schlagwort NFC.
Niervier Communications. Hab sogar ich schon von gehört, Cis.
Ja, ja, das kommt seit fünf Jahren, nächstes Jahr.
Achso, das ist sozusagen der Fusionsreaktor.
Also die Japaner haben es halt schon, in Europa streiten sich vor allen Dingen, wie das mit der Sicherheit ist. Also der große Trick, dieser Transponder macht halt im Wesentlichen genau das gleiche, wie so eine Karte, so eine kontaktlose Karte. Und damit der aber auch so sicher ist wie eine kontaktlose Karte mit einem Sicherheitschip, muss halt noch ein Sicherheitschip irgendwo im Handy sein. Und so streiten sie sich. Nokia hat im Wesentlichen eine kontaktlose Karte eingelötet. Also ein ganz normales, so ein ganz normaler Chip. Und hat dann halt die Schlüssel bei Nokia. Das finden jetzt die Telekom Operators, die die Mobilfunk-Netzbetreiber nicht so toll, weil ja die hätten ja also wer den Chip kontrolliert, kontrolliert halt wer den benutzen darf und von wem er Geld dafür kriegen kann, dass er den Chip benutzt. Deswegen finden die Mobilfunkbetreiber das nicht toll, dass der Handyhersteller das hat. Umgekehrt finden die Handyhersteller das nicht toll, wenn die Mobilfunk-Schreiber das haben. Deswegen, es gibt jetzt neuerdings einen Standard, dass man genau das Gleiche mit der SIM-Karte macht, dass also der ganze Kram mit dem Kontaktlostings in der SIM-Karte drin ist. Das soll so demnächst mal eventuell vielleicht kommen. Ich glaube, das neue Google-Telefon hat das wohl schon, aber ob es jemand benutzt, ist unklar.
Gibt es überhaupt einen Anwendungsfall dafür? Also einen in der Realität?
Ja, beim Bahnfahren.
Ja, beim Bahnfahren. Aber die haben ja dann auch wieder ein System, womit das nicht geht. Oder?
Inwiefern nicht geht?
Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht. Aber normalerweise ist es so, dass alle irgendwas in den Handys haben, was theoretisch total geil ist. Und dann denkt sich die S-Bahn was aus, womit das nicht funktioniert. Weil die irgendein eigenes System haben wollen. Das ist eigentlich das, was ich erwarte, wenn ich so, wenn ich so, dein Handy kann jetzt auch Fahrscheine, aber nur in London.
Also die sind halt wirklich, dieses NFC ist halt kein eigentlicher neuer Standard. Das ist mehr so, ja wir gucken uns mal an, was wir haben, tun noch drei Dinge dazu und nennen das NFC. NFC ist kein wohl definierter Begriff. Das sind ganz viele verschiedene Dinge. Die meisten davon rückwärts kompatibel mit existierenden RFID-Systemen.
Also auf dem Level der Uni dann.
Genau, das ist also so ein MyFair Classic Tag, der einfach drin ist und das ist dann auch andere Dinge wie Desfire Karten im Prinzip auch machen kann. Da kommen wir dann später noch mal zu, was die können. Und dann kommt es halt nur noch darauf an, dass du Zugriff auf die richtige Stelle hast, die richtigen Dinge an der richtigen Stelle installieren zu können. Da streitet man sich dann halt wieder. Das ist jetzt der Betriebssystemhersteller, der Mobilfunkbetreiber, der Handyhersteller, der Nutzer vielleicht sogar. Also dem Nutzer kann man nicht vertrauen, deswegen gar nicht. Und wer denn jetzt den Goldesel bedienen darf.
Aber eigentlich will sich der Nutzer ja nur selber vertrauen.
Also bei diesem alten Nokia-System konnte man bei Nokia einfach fragen und konnte dann halt von denen den Schlüssel kriegen. Dann haben die aber in ihrer Datenbank das Handy als unvertrauenswürdig markiert und...
Super, dann geht die Tür nicht auf.
Ja, dann kannst du halt später keine Anwendungen installieren, die ein vertrauenswürdiges Handy braucht.
Genau.
Aber es gibt durchaus auch Handy-Türöffnungsmechanismen, die auf älteren Technologien beruhen, Bluetooth oder ganz banal über einen Webbrowser. Also man ruft einfach eine Internetseite auf, wo ein Knopf drauf ist, jetzt aufmachen. Da gibt es Leute, die damit Alarmanlagen steuern.
In meinem Kopf schreit die ganze Zeit ein Marktschreier, Smart Home, Smart Home, das haben sie auch.
Oder Alarmanlagen, die teilweise über eine Webseite gesteuert werden, wo nicht mal diese SSL-Verschlüsselung, wie man sie von der Bank kennt, oder von so halbwegs vertrauenserweckenden Seiten. Aber eine Alarmanlage ein- und ausschalten, ohne Verschlüsselung, einfach nur der Klartext mit Passwort und allem Drum und Dran durch die Luft, perfekt.
Also teilweise ist es dann auch über das Internet oder wenigstens dann auch Short-Range oder über Funk.
Über das Internet.
Viele dieser Systeme schreiben sich dann die Cloud auf die Fahnen und da sind dann die Hersteller mal ganz glücklich, weil sie dann quasi die Systeme, die bei dir in der Tür sind oder bei dir zu Hause, Smart Home, an den Server beim Hersteller binden und das macht dann so kundenbindungstechnisch.
Es ist egal, wie sicher es ist, du kannst es mit deinem Smartphone bedienen und das ist cool.
Genau. Also in Amerika ist das gerade, da habe ich gerade irgendwelche Start-ups und Kick-Start und der ganze Kram und ja, wir machen das dann in der Cloud und das ist dann toll.
Ja Amerika zählt nicht, die haben auch auf dem mechanischen Markt nichts zu bieten.
Ja gut, ich glaube da gehen wir mal schnell durch, dann kommen wir nämlich zu dem großen Spaß in Amerika.
Das Gesicht hätte ich gerne fotografiert gerade.
Ja, aus unserer Sicht ist Amerika natürlich in vielen Stellen ein Entwicklungsland, was so Infrastruktur angeht, das Stromstecker können sie auch nicht.
Ja, also das erzählt auch jeder, der in Amerika war, also selbst, also ja, alle Handwerker, die so in meinem Bekanntenkreis sind, die mal in Amerika Urlaub gemacht haben, egal was für ein Handwerk es ist, dass sie ausüben, kommen zurück und sagen, das ist schlimmer als im Osten.
Handwerker, das Backhandwerk soll ja auch zu kurz kommen.
Ist alles, ich sag ja alles.
Ich glaube, das Juristenhandwerk ist da ganz gut vertreten. Ja, na gut, also wir waren bei MyFair Classic. Da gibt es halt alle möglichen Dinge, alles möglich kaputt. Man kann sich da noch viel mehr machen. Die Niederländer waren zum Beispiel, als wir das aufgemacht haben, gerade dabei ein landesweites System für öffentlichen Personen nachverkehrt darauf basierend einzuführen. Das hat sich dann auch so ein bisschen verzögert.
Da wäre die Idee gewesen, meine Kartennummer löst einen Ticketkauf aus.
Na, da ist dann also auf den MyFair Classic Karten, da sind wir jetzt wirklich schon bei intelligenteren Karten, auf den Karten was speichern kann. Da ist dann nicht mehr nur eine Kartennummer, sondern Speicher und der MyFair-Teil, deswegen heißt es Micron Fair System, daher kommt der Name. Das MyFair hat von Anfang an so eine Art elektronische Geldbörse, wo es halt Betrag auf der Karte gespeichert gibt und dann einfach Befehle gibt. Betrag incrementieren, Betrag dekrementieren und man dann die beiden Befehle an unterschiedliche Berechtigungen knüpfen kann.
Ist da dann wenigstens, also ist mein Geld dann wenigstens halbwegs oder sogar sehr vernünftig verschlüsselt?
Wie gesagt, sobald du auf die Karten zugreifen kannst, hat der Verteidiger verloren. Bei diesem ganzen System, also MyFair wird zum Beispiel immer noch eingesetzt in Berlin in der Mensa-Karte, in ganz vielen Mensa-Karten und anderen Uni-Karten, da ist dann einfach ein Schattenkonto, das also auf der anderen, irgendwo eine Datenbank im Hintergrund arbeitet, die weiß, wie viel Geld noch auf deiner Karte ist. Das ist dann zum Schutz des Kartensystembetreibers, nicht zu deinem Schutz. Du kannst halt nicht mehr Geld ausgeben, als du draufgeladen hast. Hoffentlich manchmal vielleicht.
Ihr hört Chaosradio 186 auf Fritz. Henrik referiert über elektronische Schließsysteme. Simon macht Einwürfe und ich wundere mich. Und nach den Nachrichten geht's weiter. Chaosradio 186 ist hier, glauben wir jedenfalls, dass Chaosradio 186 ist. Also wir haben demokratisch beschließen lassen, dass hier Chaosradio 186 ist.
Sehr schön.
Sehr schön haben wir das beschließen lassen. Hendrik hat gesagt, sehr schön, Simon ist auch im Studio und ich bin Holger. Es geht um elektronische Schließsysteme.
Wo waren wir? Genau, wir waren jetzt so bei besseren Karten, die nicht nur eine einfache Nummer senden, sondern halt noch irgendwas mehr können. Das allerdings regelmeistens trotzdem kaputt ist. Also Mifare Klassiker gesagt sind wir neuerdings bei, wenn man Lesegerät und Karte abhört, 90 Millisekunden zum brechen, wenn man nur die Karte in der Hand hat, so zwei Minuten, da ist das Lesegerät dann tatsächlich relativ günstig. Es gibt da so ein Projekt, das sich mit, wir waren bei NFC mal kurz, es gab eine Firma, die sich da, die da so was wie Anschub leisten wollte und einen sogenannten Touch Attack verkauft hat. Das war also ein NFC-Lesegerät mit ganz vielen Text, die man dann auf seinen Teddy-Bear kleben kann und dann gibt es irgendwie ein Programmierumgebung, wenn man seinen Teddy-Bear an das Lesegerät hält, passiert irgendwas Tolles. Aber das Lesegerät gibt es, also es war halt irgendwie so 30 Euro das Paket und das reicht völlig aus und gerade für dieses Lesegerät sind die meisten Dinge entwickelt worden. Also so ein Touch Attack hat und eine Wi-Fi Classic-Karte draufliest, sich die richtige Software aus dem Internet nimmt, dann hat man halt in ungefähr zwei Minuten den Schlüssel. Wenn man den Schlüssel hat, kann man halt auf der Karte rumschreiben oder eine neue Karte mit dem gleichen Schlüssel beschreiben und so weiter und so fort. Was noch eine kleine Hürde ist, ist, dass alle Karten eine eindeutige Seriennummer haben. Das ist jetzt aus datenschutztechnischer Sicht nicht so gut, weil die halt immer frei abrufbar ist, aber macht halt die Sicherheit an der Stelle besser, weil sie zumindest auf normalen Karten nicht änderbar ist. Du kannst halt entweder dann ein teures Gerät nehmen, wie den Proxmark oder das USRP und so tun, als wärst du eine Karte, aber du kannst halt nicht so eine 1-Euro-Karte nehmen und die Seriennummer ändern. Es gibt allerdings, wie ich weiß, in Asien irgendwo, ich weiß gar nicht mehr wo genau, ich glaube im Proxmark-Sourcecode ist da ein Hinweis, gibt es jemanden, der MyFair Classic Karten verkauft für, ich glaube, 30 Dollar das Stück oder so, wo man die Seriennummer ändern kann. Damit ist dann das auch gegessen und es gibt halt viele Systeme, erstaunlich viele Systeme, die nur die Seriennummer benutzen, auch wenn die Karte mehr könnte. Ich erinnere zum Beispiel, dass die neuen Schlösser im Jakob, Jakob und Wilhelm, so heißen die noch bestimmt, jedenfalls im Grimm-Zentrum der Humboldt-Universität in Berlin haben so was. Die haben halt an der Bibliothek vorm Eingang so Schließfächer und wenn man da seine Sachen einschließen will, kann man das mit seiner Mensa-Karte machen, es benutzt aber von der Mensa-Karte nur die Seriennummer. Und das hat sich auch mal jemand an der Uni angeguckt und hat festgestellt, nutzt nur die Seriennummer und wenn man halt die Seriennummer fälschen kann, dann kann man die Schlösser auch öffnen. Ein weiteres System, was ungefähr aus der gleichen Zeit wie MyFair Classic stammt, wäre Logic, Logic Prime genauer gesagt. Man muss immer bei diesen Dingen darauf achten. MyFair, da sag ich auch immer MyFair Classic, MyFair ist nur so der Markenname des ganzen Systems. Da hat sich NXP, die Firma, das hergestellt hat, auch so ein Ei gelegt. Die Karte, die hieß ursprünglich MyFair. Da haben sie ganz viele andere Produkte gebaut, die sie einfach auch MyFair nennen. MyFair Ultralight hat zum Beispiel technisch mit MyFair Classic nichts zu tun. Oder MyFair Deathfire. Und dann haben wir halt 2006, 2007 MyFair Classic kaputt gemacht. In der Presse stand aber immer nur MyFair ist kaputt. Schade eigentlich. Deswegen drauf achten. Bei Ledgic ist es genauso. Ledgic ist eine andere Firma aus der Schweiz diesmal. Die haben auch zwei Produkte. Das ältere ist Ledgic Prime. Ist ungefähr aus der gleichen Zeit und gleichen Bude wie MyFair Classic damals. Hatte noch so ein Hauch der Exklusivität, ein Hauch des Luxus. Ist irgendwie teuer und muss was Besonderes und ist bestimmt doll sicher. Ledgic hat sich da auch sehr...
Haben die das als Sicherheitsding verkauft?
Ledgic gehört nämlich mittlerweile zu CABA und die kommen mehr aus dem Bereich der mechanischen Schließsysteme, wo es dann auch einen Schließplan gibt und irgendeine hierarchische Gruppenschließung und so ein Kram und sowas Ähnliches hat Ledgic Prime dann auf seinen Karten gebaut. Sie nennen das genetischer Code. Genetisch klingt immer super. Ja, macht sich in der Werbung ganz großartig.
Und Doppel Helix kann man super Logos auch bauen.
Ja, ja, in der internen Doku nennen sie es einfach Stamp, was dann einfacher ist. Es ist einfach bloß eine Byte-Folge. So 1 bis 16, glaube ich, Byte. 16 klingt zu viel, sagen wir mal 10 oder 12. 12 klingt besser. So 1 bis mehrere Byte. Und man kann dann halt Berechtigungen zum Beschreiben der Karten vergeben, wenn basierend auf diesem Byte-String, auf einem Präfix von diesem Stamp. Man kann also sagen, wir haben halt irgendwie einen großen Konzern, großer Konzern mit mehreren Niederlassungen und hat einen großen Konzern mit mehreren Landesteilen. Dann kann man halt sagen, Deutschland kriegt den einen Anfang, Frankreich den anderen, Niederlande den nächsten. Dann kann man halt innerhalb Deutschlands, macht man halt die Byte-Folge einfach länger und tut einfach hinten noch ein bisschen was dran. Und dann kann man halt innerhalb Deutschlands aufteilen nach Berlin, Bonn, Frankfurt und so weiter. Und innerhalb Berlin, Bonn, Frankfurt aufteilen nach und so weiter und so fort. Und es geht dann immer von oben nach unten, dass jeder, der auf einer höheren Ebene setzt, Karten für eine niedrigere Ebene ausgeben kann. Das ist halt so ähnlich gebaut, wie das dann bei Schließsystem, Schließplänen gedacht ist. Ich stelle es sich raus, die gesamte Sicherheit, die da drin ist, wird im Lesengerät implementiert. Sie haben halt wieder so ein proprietäres System, wo sie keinem gesagt haben, wie es funktioniert. Ich habe es mir dann angeguckt. Starbuck und Karsten haben den Algorithmus rausgefunden. Ich sage jetzt nicht mal Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus. Das hat mir mein Kryptografie-Professor damals noch so schön formuliert. Eine Verschlüsselung ist es nur, wenn es einen Schlüssel hat. Da war ich bei Lejcik Prime etwas enttäuscht. Die haben zwar einen Algorithmus, der so ähnlich aussieht wie in der Stromschiffre, aber der hat keinen Schlüsseleingang. Da geht bloß eine Zahl rein, die aber vorher im Klartext übertragen wird. Also so eine Art Zufallszahl, so eine Art Nons. Das haben viele andere Systeme auch. Nennen ist dann aber extra nicht Verschlüsselung und Magic Prime hat halt sonst nichts. Wenn man halt weiß, wie es funktioniert, dann kann man Magic Prime Karten lesen und Lesegeräte bauen und Magic Prime Karten beschreiben. Denn es stellt sich raus, ist auf den Karten dieser ganze Stemm, dieser genetische Code, dieser Präfixmatch, der ganze hierarchische Kram ist nicht auf den Karten implementiert, sondern im Lesegerät. Wenn man also ein eigenes Lesegerät baut, kann man Karten beliebig verhunzen, was auch immer man möchte. Und ich kann sogar Karten, ich kann auch einen Emulator bauen, das habe ich auch gemacht, in der dann so tut, als wäre eine Karte auf der bliebige Dinge stehen, unter anderem zum Beispiel die Berechtigung für ein Lesegerät, auf Karten zu schreiben. Das hat Lechik nämlich auch gemacht, dass sie diese Berechtigung auf Karten verteilen. Das finden sie dann auch ganz toll, dass man die in Safe legen kann und so wie Schlüsselkarten im normalen Schließsystem. Dass man also nur, wenn man diese Schlüsselkarte hat, neue Schlüssel herstellen kann. Aber ich kann halt einfach solche Schlüsselkarten auch selber herstellen und dann halt ein normales, offizielles Lesegerät nehmen und damit beliebige Dinge tun. Lechik Prime ist genauso und noch viel mehr kaputt als MyFair Classic. Das war dann auch so ein bisschen...
Wenn ich meine Bude ordentlich verschließen will, mit so einem elektromagnetischen System oder einem elektronischen Schließsystem, gibt es irgendeine Stelle, zu der ich hingehen kann und sagen kann, erklären Sie mir jetzt mal, welches davon tatsächlich sicher ist? Oder bin ich darauf angewiesen, zufälligerweise mal so ein Chaosradio zu hören und dich eine Mail schicken zu können?
Für Privatanwender weiß ich da tatsächlich nichts. Ich komme darauf später noch mal zurück, aber wir haben die Firma, für die ich arbeite...
Das gibt es mir viel später, denk mal auf die Uhr.
Ja, die Firma, die ich arbeite, wir haben einen White Paper geschrieben, wo wir dann mal Best Practices for Access Control, wo wir einfach mal hingeschrieben haben, wie man sich das so vorstellt. Und die wichtigsten Punkte sind halt, keine proprietären Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen nehmen und irgendwie darauf achten, also jede Karte soll einen anderen Schlüssel haben und darauf achten, was passiert, wenn man Karten verliert und wenn man Schlösser verliert, in Anführungszeichen, also die Schlüssel bekannt werden. Und dann halt AIS oder Triple Desk nehmen, wie sich herausstellt, es gibt tatsächlich eine Karte der Firma NXP, Mifare, Deathfire, EV1 neuerdings, die sowas kann und wenn man das richtig benutzt, dann hat man schon mal keine Probleme mehr auf der Verschlüsselungsseite, keine Probleme mehr auf der Implementierungsseite, zumindest bei der EV1, die ältere ist tatsächlich schon gebrochen. Dann kann man halt nur noch in Anführungszeichen das Schlüsselmanagement verhauen, was dann halt relativ häufig passiert.
Fehler, da reiße ich.
Ja, halt irgendwie für alle Karten den gleichen Schlüssel nehmen und dann geht ein und das dann.
Das ist der Idiot, der vor dem Computer sitzt.
Ja, genau. Naja, der Idiot, der vor dem Computer sitzt, in dem das System programmiert wird. Also der Entwickler des Systems. Selbst die Systeme, wie sie Firmen benutzen, haben sowas in der Regel nicht. Also als wir das zwei Papers geschrieben haben, kamen die Firmen einfach, kamen die Firmen da plötzlich und sagten, ja wir finden keinen Anbieter, der das anbietet, wach uns das doch mal. Dann haben wir halt mit solchen Firmen, die solche Systeme herstellen, die also die Dinge zum Einbauen in die Tür herstellen, zusammengearbeitet und denen mal beigebracht, erklärt, wie man das implementieren würde, was wir uns vorgestellt haben. Sodass es jetzt also wirklich ein paar größere Firmen gibt, die ein unserer Meinung nach sicheres System einsetzen.
Es ist also nicht alles verloren. Darum geht es mir jetzt so ein bisschen.
Also ein Punkt, den ich noch kurz einschieben möchte, weil wir dann nämlich auf Vigern zu sprechen kommen. Es gibt nämlich noch, noch bevor wir bei Deathfire sind, gibt es ein System namens, gibt es eine Firma namens HID, die auch Karten herstellen. Das ältere System, wie bei Logic und bei MyFair Classic, gibt es immer irgendwie ein altes und neues System. Bei Logic ist das alte Logic Prime, das neue Logic Advanced. Bei HID ist das alte System HID Prox und das neue System HID iClass. Das alte System ist wieder so ein ID-basiertes, was man halt vergessen kann. Das neue System verwendet tatsächlich Triple Desk und Desk und Triple Desk. So wie ich gesagt habe, das braucht man. Das ist schon mal eine notwendige Voraussetzung dafür, dass es sicher ist. Wie gesagt, kann man es immer noch auf andere Ebene verhauen. Und zwar verwendet HID in der Standardeinstellung den gleichen Schlüssel für alle Karten, die sie herstellen weltweit. Also den gleichen Master Schlüssel. Wenn man also herausgefunden hat, wie das funktioniert und den Schlüssel hat, dann kann man also auch HID Karten herstellen. Ich hör dir iClass Karten. Sie haben dann halt noch für besonders vielzahlende Kunden andere Programme, wo sie dann Karten herstellen, wo man seinen eigenen Schlüssel einstellen kann. Aber das machen halt nicht wirklich viele Firmen. Das ist auch aufwendig und was passiert, wenn man den Master Schlüssel verliert? Das ist natürlich, wenn man seinem Chef das erklären will, immer so ein wichtiges Problem. Dem ist der Teil, dass die Tür nicht aufgeht, wenn ein Angreifer davor steht, gerade nicht so wichtig, ist wesentlich wichtiger. Das hab ich auch bei den anderen Firmen gelernt. Dass die Tür aufgeht, wenn der CEO davor steht mit seiner Karte. Das hab ich auch irgendwie als Feedback bei der einen Firma gehabt, dass der Mensch von der Sicherheit, der die Karten herstellt, halt wohl irgendwann mal, da gab es irgendwie ein Problem und der hat halt eine Karte hergestellt und dem Vorstandsvorsitzenden gegeben und die ging dann nicht. Und das macht man halt nur einmal in seiner Berufslaufbahn. Und beim zweiten Mal ist dann, dann war es das dann.
Das ist ein psychologisches Ding wahrscheinlich auch, wenn ich hier antanze, gehen alle Türen automatisch auf.
Genau. Und deswegen ist man auf dieser Ebene sehr bedacht, ein System zu wählen, was halt dann auch wirklich aufgeht. Halt wie gesagt, der andere Fall ist dann weniger wichtig. Etadier hat vor allen Dingen noch den lustigen Teil von dem, was sie auf den Karten speichern. Also sie haben halt so irgendwie Verschlüsselung und Authentisierung und zwar alle den gleichen Schlüssel, aber ist schon mal auf der luftigen Stelle ein bisschen verschlüsselt. Und dann übertragen sie eine Nummer. Und zwar geht das darauf zurück, dass es ein amerikanisches System ist. Und in Amerika gibt es aus historischen Gründen fast, also eigentlich überall, Vigand-Verkabelung. Vigand ist so ein Physiker.
Ich weise darauf hin, dass im Skript zur Sendung steht, Vigand, muhaha.
Ja genau. Also Vigand ist halt ein sehr lustiges 70er-Jahre Technologie. Das war halt so das erste, was man damals hatte für kontaktlos. Vigand ist ein Physiker, der hat einen Effekt gefunden an magnetischen Drähten, den dann der Vigand-Effekt heißt. Ich weiß nicht, ist ein Amerikaner, kann auch weigend sein, aber ich sag jetzt Vigand. Und der Effekt führt dazu, dass wenn man versucht, die umzumagnetisieren, dass da irgendwie so eine Kaskadenwirkung gibt, und es plötzlich anfängt ganz, also erst passiert gar nichts, sondern passiert plötzlich was, was man dann wieder sehr leicht empfangen kann. Deswegen war das damals so beliebt. Und so eine Vigan-Karte ist im Wesentlichen so ähnlich wie ein Barcode. Also es gibt da so zwei Spuren mit ganz vielen Spalten. Und dann ist entweder in der, die Spuren sind 0 und 1, und dann ist halt entweder in der Nullspalte oder in der Einspalte was drin. Und das zieht man dann durch, durch dieses magnetische Wechselfeld. Und wenn halt in der Nullspalte was drin ist, dann passiert da was, und wenn in der Einspalte was drin ist, passiert da was. Und dann hat man halt 26 Bit gespeichert, kontaktlos in den 70er Jahren, war man total glücklich. Ja, also es ist halt wieder nur so ein ID-basiertes System, vor allen Dingen mit einer sehr kurzen ID. Das zu wiegern gehört auch ein Standard, wie man diese 26 Bit aufteilt in irgendwie so und so viel Bit Housecode und so und so viel Bit Kartencode und dann auch Paritätsbits dazutut. Und dann gibt es noch eine Verkabelung durch dieses Format, durch dieses Kartenlayout hat man halt sofort nur 0 und 1 Bits. Man hat also nicht irgendwie ein Bit, was 0 oder 1 sein kann, sondern man hat einfach Spitzen bei 0 oder bei 1. Deswegen gibt es drei Kabel. Es gibt ein Massekabel, ein 1 Kabel und ein 0 Kabel. Und dann laufen halt hintereinander entweder auf dem 0 oder 1 Kabel Impulse lang. Und das ist die Standard-Vigand-Verkabelung, die auch heute noch in den USA der Hauptstandard ist für alles Mögliche. Jedes Alarmsystem, jedes Tür-Controller, jedes Türsteuerungssystem hat einen Vigand-Eingang. Und auch diese HID-Karten basieren darauf. Also diese HID-Karten haben halt auf ihnen drauf gespeichert eine Nummer. Und selbst dieser tolle, also der tollste HID-Leser mit Biometrie und Verschlüsselung und eigenem Schlüssel und allem drum und dran, gibt dann am Ende auf Wunsch nur noch einfach eine Vigand-ID aus. Da hat HID dann noch deswegen Mojaha. HID hat das natürlich sicher in Anführungszeichen gemacht. HID hat nämlich nicht nur das Standard-Vigand-Format mit 26 Bit, sondern sie haben eigene Formate definiert mit 35 Bit. Und das verkaufen sie einem dann als Sicherheitsfeature, weil ja keiner weiß, wie das Format aussieht. Also mit Format ist gemeint diese Aufteilung, welche der Bit sind jetzt der House-Code und welche sind der Karten-Code. Da kann man ja, wenn man so eine Anzahl von Bits hat, das irgendwie anders aufteilen. Da müssen ja nicht hintereinander stehen.
Ja, aber kann ich denn nicht, wenn ich einfach eine Handvoll Karten habe, das eher halten? Also wenn das sogar schon mir auffällt, dass man das irgendwie...
Ja, nee.
Dann muss das Dir doch erst recht auffallen und vor allen Dingen gelingen.
Ja, ja. In der Broschüre beschreiben Sie das trotzdem als Sicherheitsfeature, dass halt nicht jeder solche Karten herstellen kann, weil er halt nicht weiß, in Anführungszeichen, wie das Ding funktioniert. Es ist natürlich ein Sicherheitsfeature, aber es ist vor allen Dingen ein Sicherheitsfeature, um sich vor Konkurrenz zu schützen, weil halt wie gesagt nicht jeder einfach so die Karten herstellen kann, es sei denn es geht halt mit krimineller Energie dran. Und dann haben sie glaube ich sogar noch, also 35 Bit ist so das Nonplusultra bei HID. Sie haben aber glaube ich noch so längere Quotes mit 40 Bit. Aber wie gesagt, es ist alles einfach bloß eine Nummer, die gesendet wird und das dann auch egal ist. Es gab in Amerika jemanden, der sich auf einer DEFCON glaube ich das mal vorgeführt hat, hat einfach ein Gerät gebaut, was man zwischen diese Vigand Adern schaltet, was dann einfach mitschneidet, welche Karten funktionieren und dann beim Vorhalten einer bestimmten Karte einfach die alte Nummer wieder abspielt. Und so funktionieren tatsächlich auch die meisten Hobbyistenprojekte oder alles, was man so im Günstigen nicht. Wir sind jetzt ein Konzern und nehmen jetzt ein zehnmonatiges Projekt in Angriff, um alle unsere tausend Türen auszutauschen, sondern irgendwie so, wir haben eine Tür zu Hause oder wir sind ein Hackerspace mit drei Türen. All diese Projekte sind irgendwie ID basiert. Ich habe da auch eins gefunden, als ich mal danach gesucht habe, weil das war halt auch ja, es hat Vigand-Eingänge und ein paar Alarmeingänge und Türkontakte und ist dann halt wieder in die Kategorie Alban einzuordnen. Deswegen empfehle ich halt wirklich, wenn man wenn man so was haben will, muss man Deathfire nehmen. Also es gibt, wenn man so was günstig haben will, es gibt natürlich noch die teurere Variante, es gibt tatsächlich Java-Karten, die kontaktlos funktionieren. Da hat man also, es sieht genauso aus und funktioniert genauso. Man hält halt irgendwie so eine Plastikarte vor das Lesegerät und dann läuft aber auf der Karte nicht irgendein festverdrahtes Programm, sondern da ist Java drauf und das macht halt, was man will. Unter anderem eventuell auch gute Authentisierungsalgorithmen, wenn man es dann hingekriegt hat. Aber es ist halt teuer dann pro Karte. Dann liegt man halt nicht ein Euro oder zwei, sondern zehn oder fünfzehn auf den Tisch. Und das mögen viele Leute nicht. Und man muss erstmal das Java-Programm schreiben.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, da ist ja noch Folgekosten.
Genau. Deswegen würde ich tatsächlich, wenn mich jemand fragt zurzeit, Deathfire EV1 empfehlen. Da gibt es blöderweise einen großen Pferdefuß, Haken, was auch immer, wie man das formulieren möchte. NXP hat nämlich die Doku unter NDA, also Verschiegenheitserklärung. Ich kenne die Doku zwar, weil ich in der Firma damit arbeite, aber ich habe halt eine Verschiegenheitserklärung unterschrieben und kann jetzt nicht einfach irgendwas schreiben, was darauf basiert und das als Open Source weitergeben. Und es wird halt den meisten gehen, die irgendwie was damit zu tun haben. Aber ich habe mir das gerade mal angeguckt. Also du sagtest vorhin Hausautomatisierung, das gucke ich mir auch gerade so an und dann gab es so Foren. Und da hat auch jemand so was gebaut mit NFC und dann kommt eine Nummer raus und dann geht die Tür auf. Das fand ich dann, wie erwartet, war nicht so vollständig optimal, sagen wir mal, verbesserungswürdig oder mutig. Und habe mir dann überlegt, im Prinzip müsste man das mit Desfire bauen. Richtig. Gibt es aber alles noch nicht. Und dann ist mir aber aufgefallen, ich habe ein bisschen rumgegoogelt, es gibt tatsächlich jemanden, der schon mal eine Bibliothek geschrieben hat, der also entweder die NDA verletzt hat oder die Informationen irgendwo andersherr bekommen hat. Es gibt mittlerweile tatsächlich im Zusammenhang mit diesem Projekt, mit dem Touch Attack, also LibNFC heißt das Projekt, was den Touch Attack ansteuert, jemanden, der schon mal Desfire implementiert hat. Und ich gucke mir gerade mal an, ob man darauf basierend was basteln könnte, was dann auch im Niedrigpreisbereich bzw. als Open Source für so Karten funktionieren könnte. Denn der Punkt bei sowas ist ja dann, also was mir ja wichtig ist. Wir sind ja jetzt hier irgendwie bei der Sicherheit gewesen bei Tür geht auf, aber nur genau dann, wenn der Richtige davor steht. Noch schöner ist es ja, wenn man noch zum Beispiel hat, dass man nicht verfolgt werden kann. Ich habe gesagt, die Karten haben alle eine Seriennummer, die man immer abfragen kann. Die gehört nämlich zum Protokoll. Also My Fair Classic zum Beispiel kennt das gar nicht anders. Bei den neuen Desfire Karten kann man die Seriennummer oft zufällig stellen, also die benutzt im Protokoll. Und dann halt nur noch mit dem Schlüssel arbeiten. Und dann hat man halt eine Karte, wo ein Angreifer von außen nicht mehr erkennen kann, welche Karte das ist, selbst wenn er die gleiche Karte wieder sieht. Und auch nicht erkennen kann, zu welchem Schloss diese Karte gehört. Also irgendwie, jetzt wenn er keine Tauben mag und du eine Karte für deinen Taubenzüchterverein hast, kann er dir halt trotzdem nicht eins über die Rübe ziehen, weil er weiß, dass du zum Taubenzüchterverein gehörst.
Und das System weiß auch gleichzeitig nur, dass jemand drin ist, aber nicht wer drin ist.
Doch, das wäre dann... Ja, das überlege ich mir noch, ob ich das mal so in meiner Promotion vielleicht mal untersuche. Ja, das so hinzukriegen, das gibt es theoretisch auch. Das nennt sich Zero-Knowledge-Beweis. Man kann also tatsächlich etwas bauen, wo die prüfende Seite nur mitkriegt, dass derjenige, der den Beweis vorlegt, ein bestimmtes Geheimnis kennt, aber nicht das Geheimnis selber übermittelt. Oder nichts übermittelt, was auf das Geheimnisrückschlüssel zulassen würde. Du könntest also etwas bauen, das dafür sorgt. Gibt es tatsächlich auch als akademische Paper, da bräuchte man jetzt wieder Java-Karten für, weil man das erst implementieren muss. Also gibt es halt tatsächlich, dass man ganz viele Karten ausgibt. Auf allen ist ein Geheimnis drauf. Die Tür überprüft, ob derjenige, der die Karte vorlegt, ein Geheimnis hat, was in der gültigen Liste drin ist, damit man wieder Karten rausstreichen kann, weiß aber nicht, welcher von der Liste es war. Aber das ist dann aufwändige Mathematik mit ganz vielen hoch- und tiefergestellten Zahlen. Und dauert dann und ist aufwändig. Muss man erst mal bauen und darf man auch nicht falsch bauen. Und wenn jemand will was sagen.
Du musst dir das Wort einfach nehmen.
Aufwändige Elektronik oder aufwändige Mathematik bedeutet wieder, dass man lange rechnen muss, lange senden muss. Und gerade so ein System soll ja einfach sein und schnell zu montieren. Und wenn das in der Tür drin steckt und schnell zu montieren sein soll, hat das eine Akku. Und wenn man da lange senden muss und viel rechnen muss, dann ist die Akku schnell leer. Und das ist so ein großes Problem heute in der Praxis, ein sicheres System mit Verschlüsselung zu bauen, wo das Akku eine Weile hält.
Deswegen braucht man dafür einen Stromanschluss.
Und damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung angelangt.
Na gut.
Das ist Schreit nach der dritten Sendung?
Nö, ich glaube, wir sind da jetzt.
Uns reicht es jetzt?
Ja, wir sind da relativ gut durch. Also was ich sagen wollte, man kann sowas bauen, baut in der Praxis keiner. Was man aber wirklich haben kann, ist etwas, wo die Tür nur ein Pseudonym mitkriegt. Also weiß, dass es irgendwie Kartennummer mit lange Zahl ist, aber diese Zahl nur an dieser einen Tür funktioniert. Und also dein Taubenzüchterverein und dein Dackelverein nicht die gleiche Zahl benutzen und sich nicht abstimmen können, zum Beispiel. Und ja, das kann man bauen. Und ich hoffe mal, dass man das auch bald haben kann.
Ich bin gespannt. Das war Chaosradio 186. Vielen Dank, Henrik. Vielen Dank, Simon. Und ich bin Holger Klein und danke euch für die Aufmerksamkeit. Das nächste Chaosradio, dann ist es vermutlich Folge 187. Wir werden das auch dann wieder demokratisch festlegen, welche Folgen das ist. Oder der Server ist wieder in Ordnung, kann ja auch sein, gibt es am letzten Dienstag im Februar. Und zum Abschied gibt es die Instrumentalversion von Kraftfutter Mischwerks am Wolkenberg. Aus einem einzigen Grund, mir ist nichts besseres eingefallen.
Ein Podcast von Fritz.